and we are live what's up everybody it
is ebontist here with the Last Word
podcast I got my co-host Thai Guy Travis
and a special guest joining us Lord
Cognito will be joining us shortly so we
are gonna chat and catch up for a little
bit as he is literally going to be
coming in real hot to his seat around
the campfire Travis how are you doing
this evening sir been busy having fun
playing games or what's going on I'm
doing great man uh I'm working on a
review right now for a game that comes
out on July 29th that game is Xenoblade
Chronicles three that's right yeah I got
my uh my copy of that game a month early
and uh I'm working my way through it it
is a very long game it's a very long
game people but I have like a 200 hour
review or something it's gonna be a 200
hour probably play through uh insane
that is not a joke it is probably gonna
joke about 200 hours
um so yeah I'm a good chunk of the way
through the game I've had it for like a
week
um other than that my review for outrage
World Slayer went up I did a preview a
couple previews for smaller games uh
this week that went live and um yeah I
just uh I'm on the grind man I'm on the
grind also playing some Destiny yeah
also playing uh ball guys and naraka
blade Point has anybody played that
pretty great game so I haven't jumped
into that one yet it feels like to me
but yeah I was like pretty good it's
like a it's like a battle royale with
some hack and slash Souls like stuff
going on that's pretty cool
yes G-Man it is true the Xenoblade Colt
is going to come to destroy me I'm ready
for it man he's like not care it's like
unless it's a 9.9 it is not good enough
in that when it comes to that game
that's what you said before yep my
review score will never be high enough
for those fanatics but that's okay you
know like I gave it a 10. it should have
been an 11 thanks I appreciate your uh
it should have been perfect 11 out of
10. um let's just say I learned a lot
from the last time I reviewed a
Xenoblade game let's just say that I now
know they're some of their holy cows I'm
not allowed to touch and I've decided
that in my final review
though I will talk about whatever I want
to talk about I'm not going to show
footage past the first two chapters of
the game I've already recorded all the
footage that I plan on using my review
regardless of what happens because
people are so so sensitive about
spoilers if my mic is too hot I can turn
it down I got you I'll mess with it okay
I'll try and balance everybody out
I don't know I wanted to actually ask
you before we get into Destiny
um quick thoughts on outrun outriders
World Slayer uh I got Early Access I
know you did too you played it you got
your review out and
I think your score is fair
um
it's weird because I know we've
literally talked about this before like
what is the value is the price okay and
you're like I can't take that into it
what is it just for what it presents to
itself
this one I wanted to ask you just a
specific question because price aside
because you can have your debate about
that the entire time
I feel like this expansion it almost
deserves a different value because if
you buy outriders now as a full package
I feel like it's one experience versus
if you are a player who played like I
did played like 50 60 70 hours when it
came out a year ago and now I get this I
feel like those two people are going to
experience this differently
do you agree in that statement do you
feel like I played like 60 70 hours now
I jump into this I'm like
okay I see this in a certain way as
opposed to somebody who's now going to
be able to like play out writers now and
go start and go straight through the
entire thing for a full complete package
somebody who did that would certainly
have a better experience than people who
bought the game last year that is for
sure true however I was reviewing just
the new content right so I'm reviewing
the expansion so
um you know my overall thoughts are that
if you liked outriders the base game
outriders World Slayer does everything
well that the base game did except for
it does it even better but all the stuff
that it did poorly it still does them
all poorly and it's kind of it's kind of
crazy like how much they were just like
we're gonna double down on the stuff we
did great and then they're like well
what about the criticisms and they're
like yeah you know we can just
stick with the status quo yeah I mean
it's through the course yeah so
um but yeah I definitely see that point
because people who played the base
outriders game there really wasn't an
end game once you got to the end you
just had to do the same 15 missions over
and over again right and this actually
has a design done game which is great so
um yeah I I liked it a lot um it still
has a terrible story still has a few
technical glitches and stuff like that I
saw that the servers had problems I
predicted that that would happen again
that's surprising no one but it was but
it was a fun ride while I played it it's
it is a junk food video game in a good
way that should take that as a
compliment I mean me when I played it
the first time around I played like
hardcore for like about the first 50
hours and of course of like five or six
days and then like petered off a little
bit as friends had some technical issues
as you said but I was like my time I
spent with it before they're things that
the game does very well as you said and
now you have like apocalypse loot which
takes the loot system to another level
which really is kind of one of the best
things they could have done for the
entire game but then on the other side
as you said it's like how's the story
you still have the occasional like cut
scene moments and then there's weird
like loading squirts like here's a load
and it's like and then I go back to this
point and then it goes back to a
cinematic and it's just like some weird
kind of disconnected jumps and technical
things
I do think it's a fun game but it is one
of those that it's like if you played it
before if you really liked it and you
wanted more of it that's what you're
gonna get if you liked it and you kind
of Peter out and you're like oh is this
like going to reinvent the wheel nope
and I think that's that's why I was just
curious about that question so I thought
it was a fair review it's just depending
on your perspective where it coming on
you could look at the new one it's like
a five or you can see it if you bought
the whole package you're like it was
kind of an eight I mean it could fall
somewhere anywhere in there so yeah I
think calling the uh the expansion
itself of five was kind of harsh because
it it doesn't have that big a sense like
it's it is a very competent shooter it's
a lot of fun playing I played the entire
game with three people and um that's
just like it's a it's a super fun ride
it just doesn't have a whole lot of
substance it's like uh it's like a nice
um slasher movie right you know what
you're getting you go in you see the a
bunch of people get murdered the girl
gets away uh you know the movie ends
with the the back last summer you know
what you get a stream one where it's
like okay yeah it's actually cool
I'm not gonna win any uh Awards it's not
gonna win like an oscar but it's a it's
a it's a fun time and that that is
worthy of of your time and money if you
uh if you uh care to spend your time
that way so
um I had fun with it man I've always
liked the outriders in the base game and
all that so well I know Cog will be
coming in here any second but I do want
to bring this is a cog
are you sure no he's got that little uh
he's got that little rogue The Gray
Street coming in it's it's fashion he
he's he's [ __ ] told me he was going on a
new diet so I just figured yeah [ __ ]
just leaned up a whole bunch but he lost
his shoulders no everybody tonight we
are joined by the one the Legends ill
physics man how are you doing tonight
I'm doing pretty well I can't I gave you
the big lavish intro before sorry I
don't have one again no no no that one
that one was good for the entire set of
the series for sure for sure yeah you
took me back with that one so I
appreciate it yeah I'm doing good I'm
doing good I I appreciate it and thank
you so much to pleasure I'll always to
be invited and come hang out with you
you find gentlemen especially uh Trav
you know with on brand as always on
brand as always no I mean it was great
to see you in at gcx you got yes when
you your journey to get there seemed
like it was hell because I swear you got
there at one o'clock in the morning
whenever Friday night maybe you got
there they're pretty late how was gcx
for you because I know I mean we chopped
it up when we had our day afterwards but
how was gcx for you what did you what
did you think about the whole thing I
loved it I loved it
um I think that anybody attending for
the first time
um especially this is something that I
kind of kept in mind anybody attending
for the first time obviously we're still
post coveted right
um obviously that's still like a huge
concern and a lot of folks that attended
I mean it was It was kind of inescapable
the fact that some folks were going to
come down with kovid
um it seemed pretty mild across the
folks that did uh you know once they got
back so that was a blessing but uh it
was just inevitable that
um you know it was just a new beginning
for gcx right as far as vendors you know
showing up as far as you know the
density of activities and and uh and
also just the the I thought it was a
great showing as far as like I think it
went beyond my personal expectations on
how many people showed up
um and and what the actual attendance
was you know but I think everybody's
always got to keep in mind that we're
postcode this is the first gcx
um you know uh post covet and so uh for
for that keeping with expectations it
was great as far as attendance by both
vendors like I said density of
activities and things that they had for
us to do and as far as attendance and
the folks that I was able to see there
but
um I loved it I loved it it was my first
gcx um yes it was a little bit of
trouble you know getting there I had a
canceled flight on Friday but it truly
wasn't as bad as you know some some
other folks were you know unfortunately
had it like epic Dan never got to shut
up yeah never got there you know so
really yep never got there never got
these things
I hope so too I hope so too so uh but
but it was beautiful
um in the sense of uh just
in my experience at the very least all
the egos faded you know any any
perceived egos or actual egos faded
um and everybody just seemed like they
were all on the same you didn't talk to
Travis very long did you well I only
talked to Travis for about a minute you
know it's it's it's it's common
knowledge that after a minute that's
when Trav starts like you know reminding
you of where he works how he works you
know how great he is how great his hair
is you know things like that you know so
I try to keep it to a minute anytime
that we interact on a one that's how you
describe it yeah that's a that's a
that's a really good Travis friendship
meta yeah developed yeah you don't
really get close friends out of that one
just a whole bunch of acquaintances but
it's what you can do it's my specialty
um and so what but no it was it was
great because like I said it just seemed
like everybody was there to connect
everybody was there to kind of uh you
know just just mix it up have a drink
have a conversation whether short or
long
um I didn't have I didn't have a single
poor interaction whether it be with a uh
you know a peer a Creator
um and you know I was just taken aback
by I've been to different gaming cons
I've been to anime cons et cetera et
cetera I've never been to a con before
where
um folks recognize me and appreciated
the community that I've that I've built
over the last several years you know so
that was something that truly took me
back for sure
um and uh and yeah it was it was a
blessing it was a lot of fun and when
people say it uh it kind of lit kind of
a burning fire with regards to them
coming back and creating content and in
community it's it's true it's true you
know it was an inspiration so thanks
yeah I mean that was that's kind of I've
had I had one bad experience in 2019
with somebody who was like hey who are
you I was like I think I know who you
are kind of thing and they're like oh
you don't know who I am they were a
little a little high on themselves but
that was one out of literally everybody
I've met over the past couple of like
2019 no that's right yeah it was Travis
and that's why we brought him on the
podcast earlier you know who I am yeah
I don't even remember who it was at this
point but
no I really don't I can't remember the
name and it's probably because you're
just being nice yeah I agree I don't
remember I think I was like I may but
there was somebody again I didn't quite
remember the name and then they were so
much of a turd I didn't go look them up
anyway after that because I was like I'm
not gonna go like figure out who you are
so I may know the name but I probably
could get it wrong because I don't want
to call the wrong person out so that's
why I never into but no I was like same
thing like so many people are so nice
you get a chance to talk like those who
had booze were really cool to talk to or
the yeah their little booth section and
everything but I mean just running in to
anybody on the bar was so much fun to
chit chat with a bunch of people so yeah
I can't wait for 2023 and I think as you
said like gcx kovid it was kind of like
a rebuilding year for a sports team feel
like next year is Ever Enough of the
fomo is going to be in there for a lot
of people to go back we may not get
Travis back but a lot more people will
probably be going so
it's a long flight from Cali for Travis
it is dude and his britches are a little
bigger if he goes he goes to the big
cons gcx is not enough for the man who
only wears suits and Florida's too hot
for a man in suits so I mean what are
you gonna do no I'll I'll go if uh if
munchie goes I just uh I need some
distance from Florida after that you get
about a year a year and a couple months
it'll be August so at least it'll be
hotter which is good yeah I'm just glad
they're not doing it in June because
that's why I haven't been able to go in
the past as they always do like it's
either August during Gamescom or June
during E3 and I can't I have to cover
both of those events so we'll see
yep well
um
Cog will be here probably any second but
I wanted to kind of catch up with you
uh we may do this a little bit out of
order since we'll get him for some of
the story stuff I wanted to ask you with
regards to this season uh we know
obviously massive Crucible player that
you do can't pull hawkmoon out of your
hands unless it's just an odd day or
some reason so we know you'll love your
time in PvP I wanted to get your
thoughts on this season's sandbox how
it's been feeling to you if like all the
upper room Twitter is worth it where the
mods and everything are playing in how
has this season's sandbox treated you as
a generally PVP player
us I'll keep saying it I think people
are just overreacting in a lot of ways
man this is not this is not stasis meta
you know this isn't you getting Frozen
and and it just just objectively
unrewarding first person shooter you
know plays
um you know yes uh the heel meta the the
heel nade meta is is annoying but uh
it's nowhere near that man we got Bungie
has righteously you know nerfed and
adjusted some some strong special weapon
outliers in particular there's a strong
primary meta going on right now uh and
maybe that's the reason was since since
one hit kill weapons are on the decline
right
um maybe that's also the reason why I
mean
one hit kill weapons are on the decline
Primary Weapons people are you know
whether they're Peak shooting with them
or whatnot you know they actually have
to get multiple shots into the enemy in
order to take them out allowing folks
that want to heal you know to dip back
behind cover heal or whatever so maybe
that's the frustration is is you know
the one hit kill weapon usage rates uh
you know dipping uh while the ability
for people to heal and to come back for
second and third chances is increasing
based on these you know these heel
mechanics but
um I just I just think people are taken
for granted what's being thrown at them
um honestly I really do I deeply deeply
deeply feel that that's the case and I
think that people need to continue to
give it's crazy that I'm saying this you
know but people do need to continue to
give Bungie some some some time to kind
of push through this meta see what RX
3.0 is going to be about but I just I'm
having a blast for the most part yeah
there are definitely some days where the
cheese gets a little bit too much for me
where I mean that's destiny my buddy
lunar has said it right Destiny is
rarely in the best state where
you could take um the most competitive
uh game modes and you know competitive
competitive elements of the game mix
them all together in something like a
like a Flawless pool or 5500 cop and
distill that down to the degree that
you're gonna get rewarding gameplay uh
you know I say that because once you get
up like 5500 comp or you're facing 5500
teams all the time or once you're in the
flaws pool you know facing those you're
gonna get the Army oculuses you're gonna
get the Lord of wolves you're gonna get
all that together you're gonna get the
rents you're gonna get every every
oppressive mechanic you're gonna get
that mixed into many of the games that
you play in these atmospheres so yes you
know that's always kind of uh something
on on the you know on the backdrop you
have to keep in mind but other than and
those things definitely I play those
atmospheres a lot I don't play a lot of
flaws pool just because I don't I don't
subject myself to that I'm not gonna but
50 I have been playing quite a bit of
5500 comp and doing comp help and things
like that and you know there are days I
definitely have to take a break but
I think the if if there was one message
for me with regards to this meta is it's
an overreaction and people just do not
they're taken for granted you know where
we were and where we are right now
um not just
not just the meta that we're in but also
the support that PVP is currently
getting and how we are ramping up
towards lightfall to get something I
feel like I'm really feeling like it's
going to be something special a PVP is
going to be something special
um when when light lightfall gets here
so I remain optimistic I'm having a good
time in PvP of course like I said there
are days I gotta take breaks but
you know overreaction in my opinion and
folks need to just focus on the
positives for right now
um and there's plenty of them and stop
just complaining all the time and that's
again something coming from me you know
so Travis you were given that like the
the okay sign were you
where do you how how is Crucible been
treating you this season I don't think
we actually have gone into that as much
I haven't played a ton to be honest yeah
I've sort of fallen off it a bit but
although what I have played so I will
say first of all
I think people should be complaining
because that's how the game gets better
I'm a big complainer big out of it and
that is why they should delete warlocks
uh you came in on a good you you came on
on a good part oh did Cog just enter oh
I didn't see Cog enter the chat there I
was just talking okay we can't hear you
we can't hear you we can't hear you yeah
I was just finishing my 20 minute
monologue
so
yeah
good that's right uh Cog how are you
doing buddy look at me
yeah and I just I just want to clarify
again I'm not saying you know just like
just like you know I'm not saying that
folks just shouldn't complain I'm just
saying there's this there's a lot of it
there's a lot of it there's a lot of not
recognizing how far we've come that's
that's all I feel 100 so that that's
what I was going to follow up yeah
that's what I was gonna follow up with
this I 100 agree like um all right I I
think that people should be complaining
because that's that you gotta
you gotta let Bungie know what they can
improve of course at all times yes
I do think that there is a lot of
hyperbole though where people are like
making it seem like it's the end times
for Destiny PVP and I would say that
we've been through much worse we've been
through years-long content droughts for
PVP we've been through stasis we've been
through double primaries uh We've we've
been through a whole lot worse than
we're at Mountaintop I mean
although you know what's funny is people
look back at the Mountaintop and
Reckless now and are like happy about it
like oh yeah that's how you know folks
are delusional when folks are looking
back on mountaintop recluse like air
when folks are looking back oh when
folks are looking back on stasis meta
Beyond light and saying they would
prefer that over this that's how you
know I'm YouTube I mute you I don't care
who you are if you're saying some
delusional stuff like that on YouTube
100 percent I don't care who you are it
could be TTV you know what I'm saying
like like it could be it could be true
Vanguard man I would I'll mute him in a
second I swear
gonna you're getting it man delusional
yeah yeah we we've seen some things
we've been through some things
we've been through The Crucible baby
we've been through The Crucible welcome
Cog happy to have you I know you had
some stuff going on but happy to have
you here appreciate it
hey life happens that's that's why we it
helps to be able to roll with it um
wanted to ask you those we're just
literally talking about how has Crucible
felt for you just this season as a whole
so far just on an overall feeling people
complain about the mods and all that
stuff just kind of how's it felt to you
not the you know trash fire that is you
know Twitter's replies and things of
that nature it's been weird I played a
lot of Crucible this season I played a
lot of Trials this season
um
I've seen some some things you know that
that I'm not necessarily
um thrilled with but at the same time
overall I would say
right now with the the changes to
resilience you know kind of like
specking into like anti-flench kind of
builds I've been doing that
um I've seen the the the anti-air
Effectiveness stuff I I do I do agree
with that sentiment that you know even
though you got to build into it I don't
know if it really is efficient as they
would have hoped and I know they're
still tweaking things on the back end
you know matchmaking is still a problem
you know I still have issues you know
especially we talk at nauseam as a
trials player you know when there's no
freelance playlist
it's really tough it's almost for me
avoidable because it's like I know I'm
gonna get matched up you know as as the
team going up against the two stack you
know kind of a thing so almost at this
point was like let's just make freelance
mandatory kind of a bit
um as a person to play The Grind in
front of iron Lord title played a ton of
of um Rift like the idea of it
um still gotta make some tweaks there
but it overall it just felt good to play
an objective bass mode I must admit like
I did like that aspect to it so look is
it where it needs to be no you know
there's still some things that needs to
be improved in The Meta but is it like
the overall worst meta I've played no is
that we've definitely like physics said
like we've been through some really
horrible metas and the only thing I was
saying right now is I don't know what's
going on with no time to explain but I'm
down with the team because I I am
pinching heads somebody with picture by
hand because I have bro let me tell you
he's on it he's on it man you what you
want a doze man you want a dog I'm adapt
I will adapt I came in there thinking
I'm God
I can't really think I'm gone till my
little crafted God roll Peace of Mind
Elemental capacitor perpetual motion I'm
like I'm ready I got that the ideal
thing and I'm getting bodied yeah it was
like awestrika yeah Austria and peace of
mind which is getting me out of there so
I'm like you know what
let me dust this off right quick
I'm like oh man yeah yeah nice SMGs are
very nice right now side-offs are very
nice very good and the last thing I say
is I gotta say rip to to the shoddies a
little cause like yeah it's like running
down yeah it's not working and they got
they got me man I'm a lord of wolves guy
they finally got they finally they
finally took you out you mean you
deserve it you deserve it I know exactly
what type of player you are
wolves
no he's an adapt he's an adapt you know
what that means adapt just means I'm
gonna pull out that cheesy [ __ ] yeah I
mean yeah it is exactly what it means it
means I'm in a shatter dive relentlessly
until right right right yeah right I'm
gonna watch I'm gonna watch this cool
guy video real quick oh okay okay that's
that's the thing to do right now all
right I'm on it yep
I love it I love it I love it hey you
have fun you have fun hold on let me get
my clan right quick shout out to the
booty tell him he said you about to get
on Cognito don't play Dusty stop it I
saw you last night oh back for Daddy
saved with the time just playing with
his more popular content I don't even
get that I get a kid I gotta ask I gotta
ask a question I gotta ask a question so
I need a estimated time of delivery for
your Crocs sir
oh that's not happening
those are an Abomination we need to get
rid of those if you are wearing those
God Bless but I feel you have you guys
are about to have a the iron Lords
podcast is literally about to split up
into two podcasts on Sunday those who
wear Crocs and those who don't
you've been listening to the father Duke
actually and uh watching Twitter have
you not seen King on Twitter he is as
you guys say he's outside with his Crocs
yeah yes I see him today I don't know
what he did today no nothing
specifically today
you feel like the only way you can pull
off Crocs is if you have the body of
King David
I can't I can't wear Crocs yeah Travis
I've already I already have two little
too little going for me that identifies
me as a man I can't pull off Crocs oh
God it's not gonna work you know I uh
not doing yourself much of Justice
too much of a Scion to you guys you guys
could wear Crocs
two legionaries escorting their Scion
yeah yeah that's right
well we will get back to the changes
coming to the sandbox here in a second
but uh we got our sixth week of the
sever Mission we got resolved this week
we got to see kaido
work out some of her pain points and
kind of get a different side of gall
that we got towards the end I wanted to
get you guys take on this week's Mission
and then also once we kind of get our
takes I want to see where you guys think
season seven slash end of the quest may
may leave us or where we may go so
Tony
physics oh man I'm gonna have to defer I
was having a mental health week so
wow so are you okay are you okay if we
go into details about it are you okay if
we go into details about it yeah no no
no yeah no I'm fine with it uh yeah I
was just having a pretty down week I
haven't you know streamed for the last
few days I just I've been sleeping a lot
you know which is telltale signs of
having a down sometimes you gotta do
that sometimes you gotta unplug and
recover yeah just unplug uh you know
like charge back up that's it's kind of
one of the you know it fed a little bit
into I'm a Twitter guy but man like I
said when I say that or even my Twitter
has been my Twitter 99 of the time is
very pleasant like the way that I have
it set up the way that I have it curated
who I'm following who I have blocks who
have muted you know I curate that
heavily but you know even even even with
my feed you know it's it's that's that's
one of the reasons why I feel like some
of what's going on with PVP is a bit of
an overreaction is because yes I agree
complaining and you know constructive
criticism both of those necessary you
know um in order for you know developers
to get that feedback that necessary
feedback obviously we don't want it to
take it to you know harassing yawns type
levels of course of course that's not
what I'm talking about when I'm talking
about complaining but uh but it's just
gotten to the the point you know that uh
it's just I feel like it's a little a
little a little too drawn out a little
bit too much and like I said so you're
saying that um your trauma takes the
form of a toxic Twitter user slash
commenter so kaido has Gall floating
over her right okay
you've got like a whiny
toxic YouTuber or the anime profile
picture as merkules would say or
something like that yeah
so but anyway yeah it's just it's just
been kind of a tough week in any any
sort of like excess negativity you know
I don't want that to like steal my
energy so I've just been kind of blocked
that out as much as possible get some
rest and welcome back strong so I feel
we'll throw down some resonators for you
here I appreciate that I appreciate that
shout out real quick to Necromancer I've
been enjoying the cabal assistance in
these last two missions I actually did
want to shout that out
um seeing those guys actually walking
through with you and I gotta say like
the Scions if you chill next to them
they have one of the creepiest growls
of the three oh yeah just in this one
specifically when you're hanging in kind
of the fan section before you go forward
because you always have to like get the
shield and then just kind of hang in
there and just you know kind of Peter
shots at the shield but it's the Scion
itself if you get close and just let
them kind of do his little rumble or
whatever they did to that voice the
Scion is it sounds like that should be
coming from the other two but that Scion
has got like he smoked way too much and
now it's just coming out all raspy and
everything it's really hilarious but I
love the way the Scions for one how much
bigger they are when you're standing
next to them but two
um go listen to that if you get if you
gotta replay it which you probably see
have you seen the science without the
helmet on uh I don't know somebody put a
picture of that on Twitter and that
shit's been haunting my dream
y'all seriously haven't seen that yeah
y'all are ready for like a cursed
evening like go look that up like a sign
without the helmet on
that's horrifying you guys know that
part where um
that part of the of that activity oh is
that kind of the similar here I'm gonna
copy a picture just to ruin Tony's night
so he can't sleep again is it something
like this because this looks like it's
from The Raid from the Leviathan they're
supposed to be healing him yeah wow oh
god wow yeah that's that's that's
different
that's different that's different yeah
that's different okay you guys know that
part where um you jump down the fan and
then yeah there's two there's those two
big boys yeah you guys have you guys
start walking down the hallway together
that was me at gcx with me too
now you guys know what it's like
exactly I feel like that got the legion
got the legionary escorts yeah pretty
good there you go yeah
they are a little a little creepy it's
kind of like an Independence Day when
they got the shell and they peel that
thing off they peel it down yeah and you
got the creepy thing inside so yeah it's
always a little creepy so Cog I know
you're always in the story if you got a
chance to play it this week yeah yeah
caught up um it was interesting it was
interesting I I like the initial
mechanic of killing that damn gauron I
always like trapping him up and you know
I don't know I think it's funny they
made a mechanic where he this thing is
Invincible is trying to stop walking you
kind of thing so you get to the story
and um a little disappointed that it was
the golf fight again in the same space
again but that's the Cadence of what
we've been doing what did you expect
but you know it was it was interesting
listening to the dynamic and and kaido's
resolution like how she's more confident
how she's you know coming to peace with
the situation like look you know my I
may have idolized you too much and and
you know as far as because I felt he
made some strong bars against her the
last week about yo look what you got the
cabal you you're you know you're
following light bear I thought he had
strong arguments to pry away but this
week you know she's coming into her own
and was like look that what you guys did
it failed you got killed you got it
built by the travel like she has some
cold lines for him this week so I
thought that was cool I liked her
resolution you know her and her Isabella
having some nice you know sweet talks
that is that that's going to be one of
the best platonic friendships to watch
in this entire game I love when those
two talk because what have you heard the
one where they talk about knitting
yes that is so great it's a picture
those two hanging out somewhere on one
of our ships like he's up there for like
a a business lunch or something and they
have an afternoon where they're looking
out into space just like knitting and I
can just picture I'm like this is
hilarious to me because for one she's
nine foot whatever she is and zavala's
over there this you know Vanguard and
they're just sitting there with a couple
knitting needles passing the space time
away and it just kills me
hilarious I I like the development there
I was a little surprised no crow at all
on this one yeah I mean but yeah I
thought maybe we get a little bit
because I felt you know obviously we
know this is Kyle's Focus I get it but
the thing I I have a lot of I really
like the end because they said that
through a nice little monkey wrench for
me where it's like okay you think it all
right resolution everybody's you know
exercise their demons we're on to the
next thing and they were like oh no you
know kallus has made the connection to
to the pyramid there's this uneasiness
that Eris has that we are not prepared
for something I like ominous stuff like
that it gives me a little Sabbath doing
Vibe like what is she gonna do or what
is kallus gonna do something's gonna
happen I don't know if it's gonna be a
character death I don't go I'm not gonna
go that extreme but they wrapped it up
in the boat too quickly at first I
thought but then I like this ominous
leave so I I'm just sitting back what's
gonna happen next week where's this
gonna go left yeah so that's where I'm
at Travis
um
it was okay
[Laughter]
it's right it's good I mean it was
exactly kind of what I expected you know
she picked herself up and I just wonder
if um
I almost wanted to be like
you know what you have a point
I was pretty weak you know because like
uh it just seems weird for cabal to be
that in touch with their feelings like
this is pretty advanced stuff and
they're cabals they don't even have like
words for retreat I assume that mental
health is also a word that they do not
have in their vocabulary self-love
that's gotta not be one right
um so uh it'll feel those things though
that's true they just don't have a word
for it yeah that's true but uh yeah if
you eliminate the word for it you
eliminate the idea of it according to
1984 you know so gotta we got that going
on
um but yeah uh I I mean we've said all
the same criticisms before it's a little
too fast that's a little too concise uh
it's a little too self-contained it
doesn't really follow like the larger
story but for what it is it's decent
it's not as decent as that dog look at
that guy what's that who's that you're
gonna introduce that that creature to us
that Muppet she's she's been wanting to
she's been wanting to jump up for like
the last half an hour uh yes pretz this
is my this is my baby girl Prince short
for pretzel or uh it's actually a
Japanese snack so if you've heard of
Pokey sticks if you're healthy sticks
yeah it's the sister snack to that yeah
she's she's 11 years old she's a
miniature schnauzer
owls yeah I was like my my oldest just
actually just turned 10 Ryan just my
oldest you did not just describe your
dog
yeah yeah I'm sorry pretty bad pretty
Advanced for her age
10 year old husky yeah she's seen some
stuff okay yep yep you don't have to
call your kids husky okay they're big
boned
Enzo is Enzo is the Husky Enzo is the
ends of the 70 pound guy definitely
there uh no I mean I'm kind of with both
of you guys
I didn't have like big expectations
because it's week six of seven I'm
curious what happens next week we know
from the trailer that somewhere we're
gonna go into the
robot room there's gonna be a portal to
take us somewhere and as you guys have
said I enjoy what I've enjoyed like I I
enjoy just like turning the dialogue up
sound a little lower and just listening
to the characters talk because I've
really enjoyed what they've done with
just the voice acting for Gaul and kaido
both Gall especially I really like what
they did with him and then also each
week the automatons kallus is definitely
coming into his own with his just
absolute smug personality and everything
else I think he's just I can't wait to
get more of his interaction because of
whatever that voice actor is doing with
that character I'm really really
enjoying
um so it's kind of cool to see you know
now we got the resolution it is funny
when you see the little memory
projections in the helm you got Sophie
you got Aldrin and then you got Gall
who's massive compared to the other two
which is fitting but it is fun I
actually finally see those in reference
to each other
um but yeah when you finally go back and
you you expect obviously you're like all
right one two three what's gonna
something has to happen next week
because we know there's a seventh week
and then Eris doesn't seem to quite know
what's going on so are we going to go
back into the pier are we gonna like
teleport from the Leviathan to the
pyramid ship in week seven go have some
interaction in there where we fight a
different nightmare that's maybe hours
or is this a point where we get like you
know a nightmare of kind of like what we
faced before we went through Garden of
Salvation are we gonna face some kind of
like copy of ourselves I would love to
see us actually fight a nightmare
Guardian to go through that would
actually be kind of cool so I don't know
if they're gonna take it that far but
again also as you guys are saying I feel
like this is kind of a catalyst to set
up whatever something towards lightfall
is going to be I don't know if we
actually do get a tight resolution it
may be something that we might sever a
connection or something may linger I'm
just next week should be I hope is next
week lives up to kind of what they've
been building to
um yeah yeah I'm with you I I I like
being uneasy that the resolution all the
stuff that because let's be honest
heiress for the most part where she has
a plan set what we do for her generally
works and she's like genuinely like I
don't feel comfortable with this like
something is still Brewing something is
cooking what is he up to that he's
commuting still and you know I love the
callous character I think he's hilarious
first of all but um he's all he's he's
still seeking he's still looking for
what and he if he's communing with the
witness and if they could tie the
witness back in again and get us back on
track to that you know the you know we
got the TV series version and then we
have the the overarching MCU Universe
where we had Tom Farms work on and I'm
dying if they can make that connection
back to the witness again that would get
me excited because he's one of them to
be honest like that was the biggest I'm
still blown away that we saw him in
which Queen I didn't know that they
would actually do it I remember it was a
great campaign Sabbath dude okay the
whole bit and it is like yo they
actually gonna show the big early this
early too yeah I feel like this is
relatively early for that yeah
absolutely so we gotta say well yeah
they they it's gonna be quick you got to
see how this thing like the last couple
of weeks how they resolve it well not
resolve it
yeah next week will be we'll see if
there's a nice little bow on everything
or if it just kind of goes into chaos
should be
not about does not believe yeah
I mean I honestly hope it's not that's
kind of the thing I'm with you I hope
it's not perfectly wrapped up in this
little like seasonal package I hope it's
something happens that you know takes us
forward that's what I'm hoping right now
it'll be somebody going
it was all the darkness the whole time
the witness
and that'll be it
like those thing where it's like it was
just a dream
I don't know I I was gonna ask you like
what do you do you think we're ready for
a character death well that's too much
they won't do that off season
unless it's uh unless it's the uh
factions that they're literally just
getting rid of as Tom told us
wipe those just just erase those from
the character list that's fine not any
meaningful deaths I mean they can't
really do that on this it's like I don't
even know who they would go after right
now nobody's set up to be in Peril per
se yeah that's true are they gonna wrap
that are they going to wrap Cyrus as far
as uh like the uh the factions are they
gonna actually wrap that up in some sort
of like storyline
I think the factions are all yeah
factions are done like Lakshmi died and
the other one's just bailed right um
they bailed even though one of their
organizations literally existed for the
explicit purpose of not bailing
they just decided that they were going
to make that entire faction bail because
that was a good storytelling 100 with
you I did not like the new monarchy
hidea would not do that in my opinion
now what's funny everybody did what dead
orbit would do like that orbit totally
makes sense
monarchy should have stayed in some
capacity future world cult should have
all been brought to The Guillotines I
think that you know they they had uh wow
wow yeah I mean they should have they
were traded outriders they have quite we
need a strong last City okay either we
have laws or we don't have laws of
physics what are we going to do in this
last City okay
they were out of pocket Lakshmi was out
of pocket for the revolution
we got these these Fallen immigrants
coming across our borders in the last
City we gotta do something about it
y'all can't tell me like every time
every time you uh cue into like the area
like that set that second area
down bottom and they're just hanging the
Fallen or just hanging at the rails
right there unless you don't feel
something you know what I'm saying oh
every time you walk into the helm and
you turn by those two big cabal by the
door every time I'm like whoa okay it's
just like a split second reaction I'm
like yep you're still big and you're
just hanging out in here racist
that's what I'm alluding to I'm just
like no it's doing here when he walks
into that quarantine Zone with the two
big cabal he clutches his glimmer a
little more tightly you know
he hides his Exotics a little bit you
know he's worried about it I'm dead I'm
dead I'm dead I roll my windows up you
know
[Laughter]
in all seriousness they created an
atmosphere that was pretty consistent
that's what I was trying to get at they
created an atmosphere that's pretty
consistent with the feeling and and like
how some of the characters like
locksmith were talking about you know
the the Immigrant fallen and things like
that you know so that's what I was kind
of that's what I was getting you felt
that when you went to the cities like
you know the placement of these
characters
um yeah like what are they doing here
what are they doing here you know so
yeah and then you have to push back
against that of course yeah yeah it's
interesting it's interesting it was a
very intentional obviously
yes yes
it's just funny to see after that story
passes then the actual players describe
the process of now co-like sharing space
with those people and they're like a
little bit like this is going to take
some getting used to and you're like oh
my God you guys are like my grandparents
like you're just like it's kind of crazy
yeah that's true I I loved the fact that
you know budgie did push a an
interesting narrative into little you
know little real life situations into it
because let's be honest we've been
fighting these these guys for so long
right it's inherent it's you know what's
what it really resonates with me when I
had to do the the new light stuff over I
had to create other characters to get
the island because I wasn't going to do
it I literally broke my rule for that
title and I'm playing oh you did that he
said it he said it he said it yeah I did
it man I refused I was gonna do warlock
life all day and I was like wow this is
like learning that Bruce Wayne did Kill
like one or two people
yeah so we're back and I'm listening and
it's like it's so ingrained into the
initial story of Destiny of the Fallen
being the enemy and you know and then
obviously red wall campaign and now to
see how far we've come with a mythrax
and and a Cairo you know what I'm saying
it's interesting to see you guys anymore
it's not as simple anymore and that's
and that's great that's great absolutely
absolutely
yeah it's not great it's not great for
new like people by the way no man no no
it's mad I'll tell you I they got to be
if there is a single like demographic of
player that I am the most both both
concerned for and that I feel for is new
lights man yeah even before
oh most definitely mostly even before
the PVP is like how how do we even like
you really need somebody to hold your
hand for here I've got homework for you
here's six hours of the channel to go
watch everybody should buddy up yeah
like you literally need somebody to
Buddy up with you every new player that
signs in is is an assigned a mentor so
when you log in you're like hey this
character seems to play it about the
similar times as you you're there in
your fire team constantly take them with
you talk to him let's go exactly
Advocate Devil's Advocate let's go if
you were an actual Guardian who got rest
present day in the destiny 2 meta you
also wouldn't know what's going on in
the story and there would be no way to
easily catch up so maybe they're going
for realism going for realism they're
pure experience pure experience that's
right one of the better arguments I've
actually heard I'll be honest because at
least realism-wise but on the other side
it still sucks for him so it does suck
it is a terrible game design I was like
that's actually one of the better ways
I've heard it phrased that you could
play it off in the lore but on the other
side yeah there's so much amazing stuff
because I mean we had Tom on a couple
weeks ago and he was talking about the
red War missions the one where you walk
slowly and the music is slow and your
power has been stripped from you I'm
like the feeling in that mission is like
I was like I'm sorry Destiny 2 is doing
what to me right now yeah and that's
that's not even there they don't even
get to be part of Kade going through
that experience we don't get to see
older intern there's so many major cases
right now I don't know who the colonel
is
well yeah that's that's the that's the
worst part
they won't ever be able to go to you
know the arcology
my favorite Nightfall I love that knife
all so much such a great Nightfall what
Nightfall sabatoon song doesn't exist
never heard of it oh okay yeah
if you can't show me the strike no
you're right you're right you're right
you're right you'd have to really go
back and find something yeah man I like
that one too man I played that one a lot
I love Sloan too like I love slowly you
know like but yeah I love Titan Pacifica
shut up
making Devil's Advocate your whole
personality I swear that is actually
what he is I don't know I okay so I've
this is literally what he does is this
is
yes
or so I've heard that there are Sloan
stands that's all I'm saying I love I
love Sloan what'd she do she was she was
she was Battle ready she was
steady
um she was uh she looked cool
um yeah I don't know she was a straight
shooter she was a straight shooter
unfortunately she did not have a very
strong hold in the lore but like come on
man you know like this was I mean who
did at that point you know there were
only a few people at that point that
really did have I feel like a stronghold
active lore in the game where you felt
connected to them that's fair after
after they vaulted her that's when
that's when the story started to really
really started to come into play for
quite a few of our favorite uh our
favorite characters so oh yeah oh yeah
but but I I you know truth be told I
didn't have as as big of a hold with
regard like Sloane didn't have as big of
a hole for me as like arcology and some
of the you know like uh set pieces um on
Titan I really love water I love the one
I love Pacifica as far as the PvP map
I've always loved Pacifica
um it's just it's just a beautiful
planet a water Planet I love it I'm with
you on the planet I I missed that that
whole look it's
absolutely I forgot about tiger man it's
so crazy yeah yeah
well we are I guess we're not entirely
sure what's going to happen next week
but yeah it's like new players
at least in the they have it to where if
a new player starts they can see what
happens within a year that is an
improvement over previous Seasons so
we're at the point where they can
experience a whole year even if they
join in season 19 they could
theoretically play it all the pricing
models that's a different one we've
gotten into but
um before we get Arc 3.0 next season we
have some more changes coming to the
sandbox this season and I wanted to ask
our guests
a question
yeah yep so right now in the world of
Crucible and we'll cover some of the
changes in Airborne Effectiveness and
all that type of stuff that you've got
as there are so many things now in the
game
and we have this segment when it comes
to helping
the lowest man on the totem pole in PvP
this guy right here ebontists we're
going to help this guy get better in PvP
the average Joe
and uh there's things like Airborne
Effectiveness there are things like
Flinch that you can now build into so
many things that people don't know about
uh where would you say or what would you
say is kind of an important thing for
new players coming in to understand you
know they they've looked at some of the
you know the 60 40 rule or the two
second rule or some of those that
they've gotten some of those but they're
still missing some of these behind the
scenes things where would you rank the
behind the scenes priorities to learn
between you know recoil Direction stats
on your gun you've got aim assist that
now is there Airborne Effectiveness some
of these stats that we're going to know
about next season but we don't know
right now
I think Airborne Effectiveness has got
to be like the biggest thing because
people are going to intuitively come
into the game and expect for their bolts
to go where they shoot them you know
even if they do it that's weird
even if they do a small Bunny Hop off
the ground right um not like a Charged
not not a charge jump or anything like
that a burst Glide anything like that
even if they do just a little bunny hop
off the ground which looks and feels the
exact same across all three characters
their bullets are not going to fly
exactly where they shoot them right so I
think that's just something that a new
player needs to kind of keep in mind if
we just talk about like back-end things
things that are a little less known
um things that are maybe a little bit
newer
um
to the whole like PVP the the depth of
the PVP system
um
yeah
um and the the unfortunate thing about
that obviously is that like I'm not
going to go as far as I've said this
many so I'm not going to go as far as to
say that the system uh implemented was
Half Baked because I just don't agree
with that
um
because the system like is working
pretty flawlessly outside of how you
build into it
outside of how you build into it it's
working pretty flawlessly on the back
end I'm pretty sure like I feel like you
know what they intended with regards to
how aim assist ends up changing in the
air like dynamically and things like
that like that is a that's got to be a
really tough system to implement on the
back end when it has never worked like
that in the in seven eight years you
know so now now we can get into you know
like building into it and and things
like that with which they are slowly
they set it in the they just said it
hold on
so I'd like to just state it exactly how
they said it
um
we were cautious about making weapons
too easy to use while Airborne at season
17 launch preferring to take some time
to evaluate and then buff accordingly
rather than having to Nerf so like you
know it's it's a it was a it's a tough
for everybody that's concerned about AE
Airborne Effectiveness myself included
that was probably the roughest edge of
this new season launch of season 17 I
guess it's not new anymore
um you know like
yeah it was just a really it's growing
pains It's Growing Pains but going back
to exactly what you said with regards to
newest new lights I think that's the
thing that because the Flinch the Flinch
stuff it's just like your your weapon is
naturally going to have some degree of
stability to it it's naturally going to
have you're naturally going to as a new
light you're not going to Value
necessarily recovery over resilience you
know you're going to see these stats and
you're not going to necessarily know
that 100 recovery is generally what you
know PVP Mains are going to be running
you're thinking okay well you know
resilience sounds good too you're not
going to know how important that is
relative to you know mobility and
recovery so you're generally gonna and
you know you're not gonna be build
crafting so heavily so there's going to
be uh you know armor that drops with a
good amount of resilience so you're
gonna equip that just because that's
what you have or maybe that's the
highest like power level or something
like that so and I also argue and I
think most people would agree that uh
Flinch in the game is less as of a
determining Factor
um in the outcome of an engagement
versus uh Airborne Effectiveness when
you're actually trying to utilize you
know something in the air when you're
trying to shoot your gun in the air
whatnot and it your bullet doesn't fly
exactly where you're pointing it
um that's something that's heavily
impactful to the outcome of Engagement
versus getting flinched by a weapon
where you have some baseline level of
flinch resistance based on just randomly
having a certain amount of stability on
your gun and randomly having a certain
amount of resilience and that sort of
thing you already kind of built into
Flinch resilience a little bit whereas
Airborne Effectiveness nobody is just
randomly built into Airborne
Effectiveness you know you truly do at
this point have to
uh like intentionally explicitly build
into that for you to feel any sort of
difference
um and ensure that your bullets somewhat
fly where you want them to fly or where
you're shooting or where you're pointing
um you know while you're in the air so
Airborne Effectiveness has got to be
like the number one thing for new lights
to kind of keep in mind if they're you
know trying to jump into The Crucible
and have a rewarding experience
it's so interesting I'm listening to all
physics and it's like I'm thinking of
like again we want that conversation of
new light and stuff and someone in the
chat said it too like man like if one
thing about this game it is great for
Content creators because this game the
minutia and and all the different
aspects of the meta that are tweaked and
changed and then we have the the other
PVP changes that and PVE separate
changes like it's getting to their point
now where I'm looking at a new light and
I I'll use like he's not a new light but
I use Atticus example like he he
disappears for a while yeah and then he
comes back right so when he comes back
to PVP he's like okay well what's the
what's the matter like what's and I'm
like well you got a bunch of different
things you could use you know what I'm
saying you know I mean you know what you
call it hand cans are now in a good
place or this RPM SMG is in a good play
that kind of thing but I feel like every
season it does change which I the the
the Creator in me the The Meta lover in
me likes that but there's a part of me
like how can they translate this to the
new like the person who's just trying to
get into PVP not understanding what
airborne effect this is in not
understanding how to spec to recovery or
resilience and mobility and things that
would be critical for them to be at
least give them a better playing field
as a foundation as a new PVP player and
that's the struggle I'm like and someone
said in the chat like has the game I
will bring it to y'all bring it to you
he like has it gotten so complicated
like that we can't really explain it and
then they change at such a Cadence every
season like how does the new light guy
be able to compete with I mean that's
the hard part for one we already covered
story they might feel
lost is probably almost even a nice term
at that point depending on what piece
they're stepping into they're like Hey
where's kaido where is she coming from
okay we have this other season we didn't
know what was going on but I mean if you
sit there and you break down what is in
like a merkules spreadsheet you've got
cones and accuracy angles and then
you've got airborne and when you jump
and now you've got aim assist depending
on what your input method is and then
like even the way the stats work now
it's like if you jumped in and you
actually win it if there was even a
tutorial saying hey range is going to
extend how far your weapon is effective
both you know the drop-off distance and
those types of things stability the
longer you hold down the trigger The
Recoil Direction which you can't even
see in the game it's gonna Veer left
it's gonna go straight up vertical none
of that stuff is explained to a player
basically ever so when you get to a
point where a new player comes in is
like hey I point my gun and shoot cool
but then it's also how do I figure out
how this stuff works and part of it some
people can say is like okay well you can
sit there and fire a gun on the wall and
be okay this thing goes left the problem
with Destiny in which hopefully in
season 18 that's going to change is when
they said at least Airborne
Effectiveness is going to be a stat
shown in game and hopefully the other
stats are going to be that way as well
they better put aim assist recoil
Direction Airborne Effectiveness I don't
know if where Flinch would go but that's
like the things that you can build into
should be shown somewhere on your
character
right like what is the aim assist on
this weapon 23 I don't know what does
that mean well this one's only got five
okay so that's gonna help a little bit
The Recoil Direction okay show that
number and just like even dim has it
show the direction that thing's gonna go
so if I look at a wall and I'm veering
left I know why this gun has this recoil
this Direction versus this going
straight up the middle on the other side
without testing all the weapons and
going through and either finding these
websites or things like that but the
Casual person who buys Destiny checks
out the story because a friend told him
so and then plays every so often may not
care about that much stuff
and there's a lot that they can look
into but I do hopefully
see some changes in season 18 making
that a bit easier but to say that it's
complicated for a new player I think is
an easy thing to understand because I'm
sorry oh no I was just gonna say because
I listed off half of that stuff and that
probably doesn't even cover everything
of how a gun works when you try and aim
and pull a trigger and much less as you
know physics said it's like jump now you
got Airborne Effectiveness you have no
aim assist but on the ground like so
many different things affect how your
gun shoots another player that you know
a veteran has even that much more
knowledge much less just the skill skill
plus knowledge is two different things
and both are going to take time to get
to but some of them for a new player
like they're they're in a substantial
disadvantage and the learning curve is
going to be a steep one in this game I
think the last point I'll add I'll give
it to Travis um
it it almost feels like in in the new
light experience the same way we have
Sean Hahn or whatever remember in D1
there was this Quest called the true
meaning of war and Shacks would give it
to you and it would be like you would
have to get kills with like each weapon
type or just do different modes and
stuff like that and I'm wondering if we
kind of need like a handheld onboarding
obviously it's not going to be you know
intricate with all the different
statistics in minutia but just to get
someone confident in feel of of how
things work from an archetype standpoint
I think that's a mission like because
what I'm getting at is that I feel like
a lot of people they'll play it they get
demolished and they're like nope I'm
good right and they won't put in the
work or even try after having that
negative experience and Destiny's one of
those games that yeah you do you have to
put in the work but I feel if there was
a way that they could get a little bit
of a better understanding not you know
I'm not trying to take money away from
my content creators of course shout out
to face but I'm just saying like a bunch
of these two onboard PVP guys
yeah okay and with regards to what you
say like look I care about the health of
the game before I care about like
anything that that comes with regards to
my pockets you know like because in the
end I can always personally for me I
feel like I can always make some content
I can grit like you know content creator
I'm creating content you know like I
don't expect content to fall in my lap
right so I'm I'm trying to find an angle
a niche that works for me and create
content that folks enjoy that other
folks maybe don't have the the
perspective on or the angle on you know
and then kind of expand from there so I
care about the the health the health of
the community and the health of the pop
population and health of the you know
the gameplay experience that being the
case I'm 100 behind you know like them
giving some sort of like onboarding
experience because knowledge is not just
power right to just use a simple cliche
and all just power and so when when
folks know more about uh how a game a
gameplay Loop how a game is going to
operate when they jump into it then they
can set expectations and when they set
those expectations you know and the game
operates according those expectations
even if it is not
um you know the most even if it's not
immediately the way that they would want
it to be per se but at least they know
you know ahead of time then they can
make more you know more more better
decisions better decisions about whether
they want to stick with it or not I
think expectations are just such a huge
part of the gameplay experience if you
give folks
um expectations that they can see in
play
um then I feel like they can they can
better temper the downsides of a game
and push push through them to the degree
that you know they they adapt and
overcome I still think this game I mean
Gambit is screaming for a tutorial
massively for any new player to be able
to go through and say here is a tutorial
match or something like that but even
make it optional but have somewhere in
the game I mean the timeline is like a
little brief preview of the story have
somewhere in the game where like hey do
you want to learn about stats because I
will give outriders
well you know a little bit of props
because if you go into some of their
help tutorials and things like that I
think it's still there from probably a
year ago I just haven't looked they go
through a lot of detail of explaining
what this thing does what does weakness
do what does this do what does this do
what do all these things do and it could
be like range and it's like this is you
know how effective your weapon is and
there could be like a little demo video
it's like if you're this close it works
like this if you're this far away it
works like this range will help the
effectiveness like and there could be
little things just explaining what stats
on weapons mean and it would not be a
required thing to do but if that's
something like one person at Bungie
could work on putting together that
package of hearers like tutorials for
players that would be one of those
things I think that would help
especially once those stats are in game
like to go with season 18. if you see a
stat there and you're like I have no
idea how this works and it's like and
they could put that stuff in the game be
like what does your reticle look like
when you jump what is it not and there's
your fallouts and the other people who
are doing that
but it just would be one of those out
it's a it's a big ask I get that don't
get me wrong I'm a big development I get
that it's like I get that but like the
oh the way that Destiny is gonna like
Thrive his franchise is still getting
players to try it which is a harder hard
enough hurdle between the weird pricing
models that we have and then obviously
when some content goes away they hear
these things and the war stories about
it but on the other side if somebody
does try it some of those tutorials
could be in there and be like hey you
need to go do Gambit okay well you don't
tell them how to play Gambit you just
say go play
that's it I mean you don't even say hey
go pick up the moats when you have five
you get this happen unless you like have
been reading twabs or go look up a
tutorial video of how Gambit works on
YouTube there's not much in there solo
players is another discussion but that's
things brief overlays during loading
when you fly like I said it's a two you
press a gotta dig I mean to a point but
I mean you do for something like Gambit
this this pvpve mode there needs to be
some kind of explanation Travis is
laughing at me the entire time
and you guys probably think everything
I'm asking for is completely stupider or
not going to happen because it's just an
extreme request but it's just it would
be nice for that new player we already
know the story is a hurdle let's make
some of the camp mechanics in the game
somewhere that they can find even if
they're tucked away on like a help page
it doesn't have to be front and center
but if they went and looked they might
be available well I'll just say one
small thing before we toss it over to
Travis and let him bring it home for us
but
um one thing I will say is everything
doesn't have to necessarily be spelled
out too why because I'm going to video
example there's a certain fragment on
the solo 3.0 subclass that fragment says
when you get a solar weapon kill I
believe it's a solar weapon kill you
equip it when you get a solo weapon kill
it gives you restoration restoration is
the um is the perk whereby
um you get Max recovery for a certain
amount of time it's like in any Stacks
but let's just move beyond that
um and so but that's something naturally
that I'd want you know so for example
I've been using mind benders a lot which
is a solar shotgun so I shotgun one
person there's another in front of me if
I have all this stuff equipped if I have
that fragment equipped I have solo 3.0
equipped and I have that solar shotgun
equipped then I get Max recovery
instantly start getting recovery after
that first shotgun and push into the
next one to try to get that hero moment
for that second for that second shotgun
you know maybe get into a third one you
know there's three things that I need to
have equipped you know in order for that
whole process to work you know but it's
in it's intuitive I don't have to think
about it so I look back at one of my
clips
you know like a couple weeks ago and I'm
just like how did I just push through
three enemies like this you know and I
realized that restoration got procked
not only did restoration get proc once
but I I ended up killing a second one
you know with my shotgun and I think it
might have procked twice through and I
immediately went into a hand Cannon if I
that I thought I was going to lose or at
least trade on and I didn't because
restoration was still was still helping
me out with getting my recovery back
with with getting my my health and my
Shields back or whatnot so
um you know the Disney necessarily have
to be like an explanation for all these
new mechanics if it if it kind of
benefits us in
the gameplay style that we're already
you know that that's already that we're
already playing right everybody's trying
to push into that second that third in
order to get that hero moment and so if
you do that and you take that risk then
there should be some benefit if you
equip you know a few things you know two
or three things I think that's really
nice so I think that's something that
has uh you know been included in void
3.0 solar 3.0 some aspect of it um we
don't need explanations for that it's
just intuitive
Travis
yeah I mean I guess the reason I've been
quiet this whole time is just because
I agree with a lot of what you guys are
saying and you guys are kind of spitting
facts like I think one of the things a
lot of Destiny players forget is how
complicated the game is because they
live in the bubble of Destiny and it all
makes sense to them and they learned it
gradually over the course of seven years
and all that stuff but
um all you have to do is talk to
somebody for five minutes who hasn't
played the game which typically when I
do the destiny reviews I'll just bring
in like whatever friends are around me
I'll be like oh you guys you guys free
this Saturday let's get through the
witch Queen Campaign together I need to
you know record footage for the review
or whatever and when you bring a new
person into the game it is really a
surreal experience and I think uh
you know some places they probably could
use a tutorial or at least to place a
page where they could explain some
things some areas they could stand to
just make those systems more intuitive
in some way but they can't have what
they have now which is like
the remnants of seven years of systems
that have been made and unmade and
tweaked and retweaked to the point where
they are
almost impossible to navigate for the
average player
um and you know I I think part of it is
probably
do you put all your development time
into building out a system like that to
explain the game to other players when
the natural solution is that
their friends just tell them how to do
it right
um because I don't think Bungie is
designing Destiny to be a solo players
game and I think that the fact that they
don't have a tutorial or systems in game
to explain a lot of these things kind of
tells you what they think about it right
because if they built those in they'd be
like yeah this is a solo game you learn
to play on your own but they don't feel
that they need that because they have
this free Workforce of other Destiny
players that are training the next
generation of Guardians how to play the
game before them and so I think that it
really comes down to that and I hope
that uh I hope that they'll reconsider
that because it is sure hard to grow the
destiny Community when uh it's so hard
to get your foot in the door and I do
think it's one of the areas they may
need to to and I know you I've talked to
you guys about this on the show like 50
times because I talk about it every time
I review Destiny content is like dude
playing this game as an outsider looking
in you know you're I try to write
reviews for the average person right not
necessarily just talking to the bubble
of of you know devout Destiny players uh
and when you look at Destiny from that
way there's a lot to be desired a lot of
that I think is story because we just
got done talking about it but the
content involved is ravaged the destiny
story which makes it difficult but um
yeah we'll we'll see if they make any
any changes to it everything about the
way they have their business model built
right now tells me that this is not a
priority yeah I mean go ahead no you're
and that's that's a shame that's a shame
it really is because it coming
specifically from a PVP standpoint it it
has to be you know like you talk about
ravage in our population is just getting
ravaged every single day about it
um you know
um and you you said it as well the game
is and it's always it's always been like
this you know what what did what did the
CM say they said uh you know
um the real the real the real
real reward or something like that real
reward from playing this game and show
friendships right yeah I don't want to
make fun of that because I 100 believe
that and one percent feel that in this
game but they they truly if if they're
going the course that they're going they
they need to continue to just if they go
in this Direction they gotta double down
they gotta double down on the
friendships they got to double down on
the fire teams building fire teams and
finding folks to play with and making it
very easy to find folks to play with
um so that they'll have guides that new
lights and folks that are newer the
average player uh coming back whatever
else will have guides that that will
allow they'll help them catch up they'll
let them catch up
um to a lot of the new systems and
changes that happen every time folks
take a break and then come back
absolutely and the one thing I'm
actually giving some props to um Halo
infinite because one thing that I would
love them to do is as a person who's not
the greatest Halo play and I love Halo
but I I'm very mean say that again
average to Blue average that's just how
it is right and you know it could be
daunting when you know you're getting
out maneuvered and and you're really
getting you know getting frag a lot so
that bot mode got my confidence up like
it got my I got a chance because
especially with Halo which is Arena
based and it's like okay I finally got
the shotgun it's here you know I finally
got this weapon it's here on the map and
I know Dusty doesn't play exactly like
that but there is something to say about
gaining confidence with a weapon
learning how it shoots learning the
reaction the distances where it's
effective right and then you start as a
new guy okay there's a sensation
mentally when you kill someone as a new
player that she's like okay I I can hang
that's not what PVE is for though
true for PVE but for PVP when you get
obliterated in seconds and you really
don't know what happened by except on
the screen the gun that killed you yeah
that's what you get for stepping in the
arena with Gladiators like me I mean oh
here we go stay on your own playlist bro
that's all I gotta say what's the 1v1
between Travis and physics please
let's do it
are we worried about that is that is
that the content that we really want I
mean I mean it's just gonna be it's just
gonna be physics like ringing up like a
scoreboard just one two three four let's
see I would like I'm gonna just try to
skip over that act like I didn't
so so what I will say is there's
something to be said for like I like
that kind of a bot mode where folks
build confidence folks can it's tough
it's tough for anybody and then we can
Crush their dreams when they get into
the real playlist let's see you stay let
the kitty blue stay in the kitty pool
you go over there I'm just saying if
folks want to stay in the kiddie pool
till they get that confidence it's tough
Eve it's tough for even me if I if I
decide hey I want to pick up a fighting
lion and I'm gonna get good with it you
know what I'm saying step back into my
lobbies you know and then try to try to
get good with it there it's gonna be
miserable that's why that's why a lot of
folks don't hop into the general
Crucible casual playlist or not quick
play or not and try to pick up and do
something different than what they're
used to it's tough to play off meta but
it's even tougher when you gotta learn
the off meta in this meta you know so
um I like I like the concept of a bot
mode even for somebody like me just to
hop in there on the maps that like
that's the difference between PVE and
PVP as well like trying to get good in
PVE for PVP there's only so much that
you can really gain there shooting
against fallen and drags and stuff like
that
um I'd like to actually get on the maps
in the actual modes you know and and and
learn something there get some shots off
there learn my build there figure out
what works and what doesn't work what
what maybe works best in the air and
what doesn't work best in there it's it
that would definitely be something that
would help me build my confidence but
certainly someone that is uh you know a
little bit newer to the game or maybe
average a little more average at the
game as far as experience level
um to uh yeah get a little more uh
not to make every time
not to make every topic relate to my
personal pet project but uh you know
what else might help people get their
time
I saved it for you if they added some
sort of skill based ranked matchmaking
playlist Maybe where people can play
with their own skill levels in some way
and then steadily increase and unlock
rewards every season based on the rank
that they attain you know like every
other PVP game does damn it
I'm hoping we see something in season we
see that in life fall hopefully we see
that revamped comp that's been rumored
so so heavily so they've gotten a lot of
feedback on it because they're listening
to me everything we heard about about
season 19 or they're doing something
with the survival playlist
we've talked about this we've talked
about this we have literally talked
about this how re-educate and we talk
season 19 survival is getting some kind
of rework that's literally all we know
shout out to my other YouTube channel
hey there we go they're here they're
back they're back they're back they're
excited about complex sorry guys I still
can't afford ads so that's the best I
can do I'm just gonna have some comments
here shout out to Buddha be a messy I
see you bro yeah you see it you see him
yeah
[Music]
they've already established what trials
is going to be you know so just give us
a damn freelance and just be with it you
know it is what it is yeah and and folks
the the one of the
best pieces of feedback that I've
received in the last several months from
multiple people so it's been
corroborated by multiple people is I got
better the number one place that I got
better was in comp it did the number one
place that I got better was in cop it
wasn't in Trials it wasn't in quick play
it wasn't in any other playlist it
wasn't elim it was in comp that was the
number one place that I saw the biggest
like Improvement for myself as far as my
gameplay where I was able to really like
hone my style my weapons my build and uh
and see like I said discernible
Improvement so
um I feel like comp is truly for so many
reasons I could talk about this forever
for so many reasons I feel like comp is
the key to PVP not just because of what
I just said but also dragging folks like
me off of casual playlists pretty true
you know get me then you don't need a
box and they don't even give you a
Pinnacles that's the sad part I'm just
saying then you don't need one if you
get people like me that had weapons
experience that are Improvement focused
keep me entertained in comp and you
won't you won't have that level of that
degree of sweatiness you know in a
casual playlist such as quick play you
won't get people in there quite as much
farming and things like that and you
recognize that check this you recognize
that whenever trials is active or
whenever iron Banner is active
because you get all the sweaty folks go
over to those playlists you know and
then quick play is much more casual much
more as it's intended
um when those things are active so yeah
yeah definitely
in my opinion and the only thing I say
because I love everything y'all preach
it just give you some nice little
rewards while I'm in car because you
don't come back
I'd like to sweaters
most definitely yeah I mean that's part
of A ranked A ranked uh
you get to bronze you unlock the bronze
rewards at the end of the season so on
and so forth and yep then there's
something at the Platinum or whatever
they called up calling the the highest
tier that that all the sweat Lords push
for and honestly my fall from playing as
much Crucible as I used to is largely
based on how much they used to
incentivize you versus how much they
don't now to do it um and it's not even
the incentive of like oh Travis you need
you need a reward you need a trophy to
feel like you did something it's really
just like the incentive of getting to
play against higher skilled people
because now you you know you can grind
the survival playlist as much as you
want you're going to be playing against
the same random hodgepodge of of loosely
thrown together uh people uh and I
that's just that's not not a very fun
experience is uh is rolling the dice
every time you enter the matchmaking
Lobby it should there should be skill
based matchmaking there just should that
way I can play with my peers and get
better iron sharpens iron man
um you don't get any better playing
against random people with random squads
and yada yada it's just it's just not
fun yeah yeah well and and keep in mind
just to you know
just to clean that up of course there is
skill based matchmaking in uh in comp
you know but but it's not it's not to
the degree that Travis is talking about
it's not to the to the you know to that
point most definitely and in my
experience I've been playing actually a
lot of 5500 comp where I just sit at 55.
um until I lose the game because I'm not
infallible of course
um and you're right like I play random
games against folks that are you know a
variety of of comp ranks and then I'll
play maybe a few games here and there
against folks that are 55 or right
around 55 or something like that and
I'll I'll keep saying it as we again the
sandbox is rarely in a good state where
the games that I play at 5500 level are
against opponents where everybody is
trying to display actual skill as
opposed to folks are just trying to win
the game you know right when you say
their skill based match breaking and
survival you're talking about the um the
the rank it's rank based right like
people who are yeah it's actually skill
based when I when I start out at zero at
zero uh rank I'm generally going to be
facing folks that are within my my skill
range my combat rating however they do
the MMR they they switch that up a while
back
really I was talking to somebody who
seems to know a lot about this recently
and he seems to think that it actually
has more to do with your play time than
actual skill and so it might have like
an app wouldn't be you have an abnormal
amount of play time then you get you get
matched up against people who are at
like the highest skill level and have a
similar amount of play time even if
you're not better of a player which I
wouldn't describe as skill based I would
agree with that well I mean you know we
could talk about we could go back and
talk about what what skill based
matchmaking is to Destiny right because
Lobby balancing you know wasn't Guild
based matchmaking not the way that they
you know came onto it it was very very
lawyer yeah yeah exactly so I'm not sure
how they end up dictating what the skill
is
um for comp it very well could be
experience which obviously is not a
one-to-one with actual uh with actual
skill
um but uh nonetheless nonetheless uh I
would love to see exactly what you
talked about a real ranked playlist
um one that incentivizes New York folks
to to get better and helps them actually
get better without being too oppressive
to
um to to off-putting and a playlist at
the same time that at the same time
holds interest for folks like me who are
you know have a you know years and years
of experience and keeps me as much as
possible out of the Casual playlist
unless I truly want to play casually
pick up something that I don't usually
pick up and just have fun and I've said
this a bunch I I just like I wish like a
lot of folks love the the Mayhem the
chaos of sixes and all these very very
fun elements you know just rocking their
don't Nerf anything just have a year one
you know D1 and everything's op and that
sort of thing I don't I'm not I'm
obviously making it hyperbole a little
bit with that but my point is just
restrict some stuff in the in Trials
restrict some stuff in comp and let
casual play quick play just be as silly
as as it wants to be you know
um because a lot of people really love
that that that pure Space Magic really
silly casual you know what if you play
quick play experience
um and then you know there's other
people of course like me that like a
more rewarding
um you know
um engagement experience something a
little more a little more balanced so I
don't know it you know it's a challenge
either way for Bungie I'm not gonna say
that's something that's easier an easy
formula but uh but yeah I do truly
believe that comp is the uh is the
answer for a lot of this stuff I agree I
think they're sitting on it and you guys
are excited me I didn't somehow I missed
that what he had talked about about it
was a season 19 you said and he's in 19
there's supposed to be something I can't
remember exactly when it was mentioned
I'm pretty sure it was a 12 or something
they mentioned but yeah 19 is when some
kind of survival comp
something's going to happen to that it's
that's all we know so it's like that's
when it's like we can cross our fingers
we might see something along those lines
like I would imagine that would be very
very well received
um I do hope if they are going to do
something like that
they use The Crucible Labs playlist
during part of 18 to work out a few of
the Kinks because every so often when we
get something like Rift and be like hey
some stuff's busted how about we try
some of these things before they launch
Now Grant and I know some of them could
be coming in hot but if you're
rebuilding a system use labs and be like
full beta phase I don't care what flag
you have to throw on there let us see
how it ranks out just even for a little
while just to get a feel for the system
before it's like here's the launch and
then you might get a patch six weeks
later to fix some of it that and that I
would love to see this again to my to my
what I was talking about with regards to
expectations because the thing is if you
do that it's Crucible raps it's a beta
everybody knows it is you know then
everybody comes in and nobody expects it
to work
in a rewarding sense you know nobody
everybody expects there to be some chaos
with it everybody expects it to be kind
of messed up here or there
um and everybody is willing to give that
feedback whether it ends up being some
complaints or whether it ends up being
actionable feedbacks you know um so it
just speaks to I just feel like a lot of
a lot of our Strife in the PVP Community
is and just the community at large but
the PVP Community is due to just
expectations
um and managing those I feel like if
Bungie can do a better job of that and
give us give us Arenas where that can be
tested where they can clearly outline
what your expectation should be and then
I feel like we'd be better off people
would be able to temper those downsides
a lot more easily the biggest thing with
AE remember the biggest thing with AE
that people beef with is not how AE
really dropped it's how they set the
expectations prior to it dropping
that was the biggest problem with AE
period
well speaking of Airborne Effectiveness
we got a little bit of a change with
regards to the twab this will be coming
up in I don't know if they State win
I would expect these changes to shift
the PV meta for a month or so before
season 18 launched so this will be kind
of like a mid-season maybe the solstice
update I don't think it's dated right
now uh but they basically say Airborne
Effectiveness they're going to improve
the Baseline Airborne accuracy for aim
assist for all Primary Weapons they're
going to add a static Airborne
Effectiveness buff to some existing
perks and raise the base Airborne
Effectiveness stat for several exotic
weapons uh they're gonna turn tune some
uh primary weapon sub families shotgun
PVE damage stuff like that so I mean big
things if you want to go through and
read all the minutia you can see that
you know they reduce the Airborne
Effectiveness penalty for low Airborne
Effectiveness stat by about 20 to 40
percent uh the higher you are they still
lower some of that down
uh they reduce the aim assist penalties
for the certain weapon types
um depending on your input method
depending on if it's aim assist or if
you're talking about bullet bending or
reticle stickiness also things like air
assault is now plus 10 all the time as
opposed to its weird low Health thing
that's plus 60 extended mag they had to
give people a reason to try and use that
one that's plus 10 steady around to
seven
um and cannons I did want to kind of go
I'll kind of go through a couple of
these and see in canons 180s body shot
damage is going from 37 to 40. [ __ ] goes
from 57 to 60. can now kill in two crit
two Bonnie auto rifles so 450s have
fallen behind the body shot's gonna go
from 19 to 20. Precision damage
multiplier moves to basically keep that
the same Scout rifles you've got
Precision which are 180 and high impact
150s uh precisions go from body damage
getting a boost
um from 34 to 38 and then crits going
from 54 to 60.8 I am packed Scouts go
from body down damage from 38 to 42 and
[ __ ] moves from 66 to 73.
basically two crit one body against 189
which no one runs that anymore
shotguns do get a boost in PVE they
increase the pellet shotgun damage bonus
from 10 to 25 so it's getting an
additional 15 linear Fusions for PVE are
not going to get flinched like crazy I
don't know if you guys have used those
in PV but man there's sometimes it hits
way too hard I understand PVE they were
trying to tame him back but or PVP but
PVE you would feel it slaves they're
fixing Special ammo bricks for glaives
Ariana's valve faux tracer
couple or not flow Tracer um
for Runner 4Runner thank you yes yeah so
they were not getting enough Special
ammo brick to be functional if you
picked up a brick so now they just made
them actually work correctly Exotics
Lawrence driver aim assist has been
reduced and knocked down also reduced
the suction against players when you get
that one yeah that one's been asked for
for a very long time
uh gallaghorn primary rocket no longer
has proximity detonation so you will
have the actual
um
basically the direct impact then you're
going to have the explosion and then
also the wolf backgrounds now do half
damage to players so if you're trying to
run away it's not probably going to
insta-kill you biggest thing of all that
probably went through Twitter was last
word reduced Precision fire or hip fire
Precision aim angled by 50
Precision aim angle dictates how far off
the head you can be aimed and still have
aim assist Grant you a critical head
instead of a body reduce the damage and
aim assist fall off by three meters as
well that's probably the biggest one
taking a shot and it was specifically
for controller
yeah yeah we're definitely eating I
didn't necessarily have a problem with
it but man y'all were eating good yeah
and then everything else is mostly the
Special ammo
Special ammo and then Exotics kind of
get certain surros getting a buff for
Airborne Effectiveness uh Whisper of the
worms just an odd one to me if somebody
uses that in PvP I would love to see
them do it
um Monte Carlo yeah it's for a clip yeah
exactly Monte Carlo 21 to 29 4Runner 22
to 27. um that's basically the main
changes come in any big highlights from
you uh physics first anything from the
Airborne Effectiveness or the archetypes
like hand cannons Auto Scouts anything
kind of shout down to you as
yeah some standouts last word definitely
taking an L there I mean they had their
time in the sun I honestly didn't have
too much of an issue with it just
because mnk has their weapons yeah you
know DMT being the one that uh that's uh
that comes to mind first and foremost
um so I you know I didn't mind I didn't
mind the last word really being being
strong and I knew we all knew that it
was eventually going to get nerfed so
I'm glad that folks had their time to
sign I'm also a big last word fan from
D1 last word snipe from D1 so that's
another reason why you know I wasn't
really too heavy about like knocking it
anytime soon so it's about time but it's
cool it's cool I didn't really have too
much of an issue with it when it was
making us run forerunners the one that
sticks out stuck out to me when I read
this entire document Forerunner stuck
out to me why because forerun is already
a monster it's kind of a sleeper it's a
sidearm also which can be run with
mechaner's trick sleeves yes which gets
all the benefits of just being a sidearm
in general sidearms have been strong for
a very long time it's just people I
guess prefer myself included
um prefer shotguns or whatnot but
they've been strong for a very long time
there's a lot of synergy between a bunch
of different Exotics and builds with
sidearms
um and so it's going to be really
interesting to see how those builds
continue to flush out
um as you know sidearms continue to
creep its way into the meta but
Forerunner is very strong and the fact
that like it doesn't seem like a lot the
fact that they're getting one more
bullet per per brick but it kind of it
kind of is it just adds to the
Forgiveness of the weapon to get more
and more people onto it
um but the other thing that uh really
stood out to me was that forerunners as
well was getting a buff from 22 Airborne
effect missed at 27. you know
and with their the increasing ability as
we're going to see coming into you know
diving into the next season of the
ability to
um build into more and more Airborne
Effectiveness you could see Forerunner
people getting in the air a lot more
with Forerunner making those plays that
thing hits hard it hits hard I always
remember back to my buddy lunars you
know one of the reasons why whenever I
see lunars in quick play and I'm on the
opposite team I very very quickly
consider
backing out
one time yo Lou is just a monster with
whatever he picks up he slid a corner I
I came into a game didn't know he was in
there endless Veil this is the story I
always tell endless Veil I go up to the
mid the game's already in progress I go
up to Mid and I didn't realize also why
people were backing out of this game
that I would get loaded into it okay so
I get loaded in again into a game in
progress onto the opposite team from Lou
I immediately go to endless fail I
immediately slide up to the Middle Lane
everybody knows that Middle Lane on
endless fail Lou immediately
slides that three Taps be a forerunner
my my finger automatically goes to the
orbit button
that game I'm out of that game before I
even respawn before I even respawn
Forerunner is is 100 slept on the
Synergy between Forerunner and
meccaneers trick sleeves and a couple of
other mechanics in the game 100 slept on
they're making more forgiving with
regards to the ammo and they're giving
you some additional forgiveness in the
air as well Forerunner is a sleeper is a
sleeper for sure that was the first
thing that stuck out to me
um gallahorn obviously I think that's a
pretty substantial obviously a pretty
substantial Nerf but you know probably
deserved it simply because it was the
number one pick in PvP for a heavy it
was just a no-brainer hey you got the
galley okay you pick it up you know it
is what it is um and galley's been on
top for like a while love the Exotic but
it's time for a change up Lawrence
driver can die in a ditch
you know I just I just need that to go I
agree dude that is the most annoying
weapon in trials that is the most
unrewarding weapon to go against in the
game and has been for nine months I had
a tweet a while back where I was just
like what did I say something something
got fixed oh it was it was um right
right when witch Queen dropped I said
something along the line of wow Laura
Lee after what like a week yeah got got
switched up you know yeah the rent's
driver has been terrorizing like for
months months months six seven months
you know what's good in a game mode
that's all about working together a
weapon that that punishes you for
working together because if one of you
gets hit and you all die that's a great
idea
think about if Cloud strike was
presented exactly
the same sort of thing but here's the
thing flash strike actually takes a
little bit of it's Cloud strike takes a
lot more skills you actually got to hit
that shot obviously the hitboxes aren't
as big yes you have to hit that shot
um and you know there is something to be
said people are just like man why are we
nerfing and buffing Things based on
usage and it's just like yeah we
shouldn't talk about usage all the time
but I've said it a billion times and you
know I'm sure other people have as well
it's not a unique idea it's just like I
want folks to have fun easy of use isn't
everything when it comes to talking
about like nerfing and buffing things
usage rates and how often I see that and
how often that you know you know me
trying to like slide out on a cloud
strike and you know my entire team gets
deleted if that doesn't happen too often
then it you know like it make it it's a
clip it's a clip and if it's a clip and
I don't see it too often have fun with
it have fun with it Lorenz just happened
all the time all the time man and it's
just one of the most if not the most
unrewarding thing to play against for
the last like better part of the year so
anyway in a ditch uh Precision just so
you know everything that you're saying
right now is ensuring that Cog is going
to start using Lawrence drivers
you're giving them the keys to the
cheese car this is uh now that he can't
use his lore wolves oh is that is that
is that one too much for you I was
wearing Lord Awards before anybody knew
it was here anybody else in chat said
that that's true bro I got history this
before was meta people were sleeping on
it now I was telling people I'm like yo
it's a beast because it doesn't operate
like a typical shotgun but yeah you
gotta give me a little credit you know I
always go against the grain like I'm the
guy that I would try to literally start
up the podcast saying hey no time to
explain and I saw that debate on Twitter
this week I was like wait a minute hold
on hold on this is the anti-meta guy
being like how meta can I be my
investigation you know what I'm saying
hold on let me see how the matter feels
all the meadow feels pretty good this
feels nice the water feels fine over
here that's a little cheesy
give me a little credit I usually go
against the great I'm usually the guy
that's pucking up the sidearms and
picking up the SMGs I'm not I've never
really been a shotgun ape I've never
been what everyone is using I always try
to find something in the cut that's
solid that most people are not using but
um it's funny you said that with with
this this whole meta going on I got a
lot of the thing that excites me
180s because right now like bro I was
about to say yep
I'm gonna be brutally honest 180 is an
archetype I don't use in any game now I
don't use it in PV because it does it to
be hit hard enough and then PVP I'm like
I feel like I'm just tickling people
with this thing and I'm just like nah
man so 180s needed it and I I'm sitting
on some really solid rolls of 180s that
I've had for a while and I I would love
to see 180s have I don't I don't
have we ever had a 180 meta yeah of
course not forgotten what you mean oh I
never had it
was it 180 150 yeah no 180 it was it was
the the strongest and most represented
180s uh like not forgotten by far Luna's
house obviously by extension
um and trust with explosive payload
everyone had to run see I hate like
everybody's like oh the trust man I'm
like I pick up trust and I'm like this
feels like ass to me like 180s have felt
terrible for a long time and again
that's just me as a user it's like it
never felt are you on mnk mnk yeah but
that's M K it's it's 180s are they're
controller weapons they they definitely
gravitate they're definitely cater more
towards uh controllers you know so um so
yeah uh what just like you said the
other two things that stuck out to me
was the fact that
um you know obviously you know Airborne
Effectiveness is getting buffed across
the board for the most part but uh
Precision Precision hand can it's 180s
becoming more forgiving I think that
a lot of a lot of us have been talking
about the fact that look if we want
folks to primary more you we have to
look at specifically making certain
primaries more uh you know more
forgiving to use that's how you're going
to get some some more folks on them so
180s they did I feel like they did a
great job in this particular buff for
180s and hopefully we will see more 180s
being represented in the meta because of
it
um high impact I'm sorry uh uh which one
was it it was 180 Scouts precisions
sorry yeah yeah yeah I'm sorry what yeah
is it is it high impact Scouts high
impact is 150 Precision Scouts yes
Precision Scouts were the ones that
stood out to me for sure the fact that
you're getting increased body damage
from 34 to 38 increased crit from 54.4
to 60.8 that's chunky that's chunky yeah
they're gonna do some damage I'm trying
to look at what I got in the car
stop oh stop oh stop I didn't see what I
gotta go to pull out all these boys so
that was another one that that was the
last one that really like heavily stood
out to me so if you've got a 180
Precision Scout after this update I
would heavily consider bringing that out
especially if you're a big lover of
scout rifles for sure those things are
going to hit uh very very hard become
you know increasingly forgiving
um with this update so so yeah okay
that's nice that's nice yeah that's most
of what's in the 12 that's basically a
little preview of sandbox changes and
most everything else is just you know
known issues and still light on the 12
um we do have grand Masters starting
next week iron Banner is the week after
so those are kind of the preview of
what's coming ahead
and I'm looking forward to you know DFA
coming back Adept and actually I will
actually farm that see what I like about
it obviously the perk pull forward isn't
as stacked as you know for PVP as uh as
some of these other you know
um like in-game hand cannons but yeah
but that'll be interesting I'll
definitely be in there to try to get get
a nice roll on that
yes sir yes sir but just off that Vision
the Confluence sorry
he's literally in his dim right now
not on the podcast at all just all about
the Dem I got you I get excited this is
with this is what the vault is to my
advantage I'm like oh that's a good one
not better right now but I know one day
we're gonna dust that off take that for
a spin I'm ready
yeah especially with it I I really feel
what it is bad they needed it yeah a lot
of people love love 180s um they're not
my favorite at all
but I'm happy to see you know a weapon
that a lot of people have a lot of love
for get some you know get some help in
the in the Forgiveness department so we
see some better representation
a lot of people think look I don't
always want it to be a 140 shotgun meta
people
man I tell you I can't talk on Twitter I
cannot even say anything on Twitter
without some gem coming through telling
me that you know making assumptions
based on the hand Cannon and the shotgun
that I use like bruh I want some
diversity I do not care whether it's a
hand Cannon shotgun meta I just want the
weapons that that I love to be effective
you know in its intended ranges and as
it was intended started sorry to cut you
off Travis
no it's all good I was just gonna say
I'm a defender of 180 so oh hey then
yeah I mean those were hand cannons
always felt the best and the 180 met him
back in the day
yeah dude you didn't use not forgotten
that was the weapon for so long
yeah and then physics got Hawkman and
he's like oh this is bad
I'm telling people hawkmoon keeps me
playing the game you want me to keep
playing the game just keep hawkmoon
exactly how it is and make sure that it
doesn't become I don't want Hawkman to
come meta then if it becomes meta it
just you know at some point I just want
to use something else do you have a
gambling addiction no yeah there's no
gamble with my hand can't a shot boy I'm
telling you no gamble I'm gonna
definitely hit that six seven and then
somebody's getting tapped okay
why if I see him in a Lobby I turn
around and walk out that door
back out I was like we shouldn't be
matched together and if we are that's
not gonna be a fun day for me
somebody's getting tapped right here and
I'll get I'll be kind of I'll get kind
of ego about
well that pretty much covers what we've
got going for the week but I wanted to
ask you guys as we get to season seven
we know what was going to be likely the
final quest step
um the big question is what is going to
keep you guys going until season
18. between the quest kind of wrapping
up we know I got GM's I mean he had you
know farm and DFA might be a thing in
there how much do you guys see yourself
sticking with this season I've heard
some people saying this season might be
getting a little lighter and stuff we've
kind of talked about activities versus
crafting grind and stuff like that how
much do you see your guys you know play
time in Destiny do you see a tapering
steady increasing where you guys at for
you know upcoming six seven weeks till
we get 18.
I'll go first
I see my play time going up insanely
as of next Tuesday when iron Banner
opens because I still need to get that
done because I wasn't available
next week is GM's and the quest then
it's then it's iron Banner so after iron
Banner what you got left
That's it man I mean uh I'll still do
Duality I'll do Duality every week until
I get the sword I still don't have it um
other than that I'm I'm interested to
see there's not really a lot to chase
right now I mean I don't really have
this much time to play Destiny as I did
in the back of the day anyway but uh I
do want to get back into it I would like
to get you know my my Crucible skills
are undoubtedly Rusty I just haven't
haven't had as much time to get as
sweaty as I like to get so
um but yeah I I suspect it'll go up uh
in two weeks when iron Banner goes goes
on and then uh probably down a whole lot
actually you know it's probably best
that it's the week after next week
because next week I'll have to do all
the story stuff and then it'll be done
and then iron Banner will show up just
in time for there to be nothing to do in
Destiny's PVE so
we got Solstice of hero or Solstice now
coming up the week after our own Banner
yeah oh anybody still need to do Duality
this week what's what's up
actually I do
what you doing it right after
unless I end up waiting for you for two
hours
here we go it's me for the leave me at
the altar for for you got the teddy the
teasing one
I haven't talked to him but yeah he's
probably down anyway
yeah for me it's just um
I can't get incandescent on the damn
mighty multi-tools
I got four and I'm like come on give me
this report already
you can just pick up the red the last
red border uh from yeah
four like
a perk from the mask the mask offers a
perk where you get yeah I got it already
that's how I got the four oh okay next
week you gotta wait till next week it
sounds like you just you real it sounds
like you're real entitled right now
[Music]
in it I'm saying it I feel like you'd
have if you've had that perk unlocked
for a bit I feel like you'd have five by
now if you actually put some time into
the activity oh called out
oh my God you gotta put down that demio
and play you some Destiny before you
start complaining about these drops sir
um you don't have the iron Lord title
yeah
David so I put in some time now I put it
down we gonna do this
I have just been unlucky with that damn
role that's just what it is I want to
have fun with ignitions I want to do
what other people are doing so I need
that and then I need
um these Storm Chaser that bad well it
should be a fair fighting Travis yeah I
need style Soul chest so I gotta do a
duality joint and a better roll probably
with the trials
um Saturn like Fusion
I didn't even I didn't even get that I
didn't even get that yet that has not
dropped so um there's like a little
little odds and ends just little odds
and cleanups yeah and then from there
I'll probably just wind down I hear
outriders is doing something me you know
see what's going on with that and shout
out to Travis with his amazing review
which I watched in its entirety it was
really good
um yeah there's a couple of holes in in
my game I just gotta get cleaned up
physics and then once I do that you're
gonna throw that damn casual title on me
boys
throw me all the way to the bushes I was
like they did oh my God come on that's
what it sounds like it sounds like I'm
1v1 and everybody that's what it sounds
like
I know here we go this actually should
be this actually would be fun me in
physics versus YouTube
oh yeah
because I'm the schlub who has an entire
podcast suspect made he's right [ __ ]
he's right he would just bring down her
KD and give him extra points
I feel like some some stuff needs to
work out between y'all
guys just stuff to work we like can't
work campfire therapy session if you
need to solo a dungeon e is your guy
okay that's all I gotta say on that one
because you're not you're not wrong but
yeah that's why I said lowest common
denominator when it comes to PVP skill
I'm the one who has a segment about me
so I get paired with the you know
hawkmoon beast mode and then we got they
gotta bring out the hawkmoon for that I
don't think that would be perfect but
then Coggin I win by just targeting e
that's how we win we target we avoid ill
as often as possible
it's gonna be difficult when I attach
myself to him and we're running together
there's a reason why I changed my name
to primary me you coward that happens a
lot primary me you cowards that's
awesome that was my one name change
Midstream I got so frustrated by people
running away or hitting me with some
some
dude
that is 100 that's honestly my goal in
life is to have people I want I want
people in real life to Flinch when I
speak that's my goal in real life
it's not it's not as fun as you might
think it's not as funny as you might oh
no it doesn't sound fun but it's really
not about being fun it's about you know
if we could actually put that together I
think that'd be fun I think that'd be a
nice tune oh my God Coggin I would get
her ass kicked with my rusty skills
right now and cards
midnight or something like that trust me
I wouldn't put on something
you know where I'd actually be able to
reach out and touch folks you know
light on us with me okay he'd kill us
with all Blues just uh
he's using a blue
man on you even though he hasn't even
picked up an ammo break yet
that is hilarious
yeah what about you uh who who else
didn't eat you said you got left yeah oh
no me yeah I was like um mine's gonna be
the same thing kind of working on
uh just trying to get the sword from
Duality working on crafted frames just
kind of doing those casually make sure I
take advantage of the you know red
outliner do a little nightmare see if I
get the drop knocking out some triumphs
and you know I do have to get my iron
Lord title I didn't get to get to it
last time but just you know focused on
the dungeon and everything else had
different priorities so things happened
oh yeah different priorities oh yeah but
I get caught casual okay cool
you have to get like dragged into the
dungeon it sounds like two hours later I
do it's just that Travis always was to
do it like after the pocket I'm like we
got all these other days where I got all
that time to rock out and he'd be like
all right this specific window is what
I'm gonna do and then I get called out
shame named and shamed if I can't make
that specific window the man I'm
available hey what you guys need to do
they make calendars you know set a
Google Calendar appointment and just be
like hey you know if you're not
available after the podcast you just say
no bro you don't have to say yes and
then keep me waiting you know
the reason I set it up on the podcast is
because I'm already talking to you and
other times you know I hit you up and
you leave me on red and I just start
here
dude seriously I I here this is a true
story I texted Cog once and I said Cog
let's do the raid and he gave me the
phone number of his secretary and said
go ahead and schedule something with her
yeah he told you to call Maddie
is that what the last words
he's like I gotta get approval from uh
Last Stand media I need the time off
please
no yeah so I I call Cog and then
somebody picks up and says you've
reached cogs lying how may I help you
and I'm like yeah
they gave me they gave me a ticket
number they're like can I have your name
as long as it's not Beetlejuice where
it's like 9 million you're good with
like a like the ticket and the number it
was a raffle ticket yo that's right you
might you might get to play with cogs
there's a chance
that's wild right there
it's a very bureaucratic process yeah
that's that's what it's like when you
try gaming with the Lord you know he's
got a big title for a reason you know
and a Duke he's a Duke too oh yeah
that's a hilarious right now you know
that yeah SOLO Duality sir too yeah Mr
solo gamer you know
bring it back here as far as like uh
where I see myself uh the rest of the
season yes
um no no worries no worries um yeah I
mean I'll still be definitely playing a
city and picking him out of you know PVP
and um and Destiny 2 uh like farming the
containment
is is definitely very attractive to me
it's not a weapon that I feel like I
pick up a lot but it said weapon that
I'd add at least I'd at least want to be
available to me to craft
um that's a hit different bro it does it
does and that leads me to my mini tool
which is fantastic in both PVE and PVP I
could definitely see myself picking that
up a little more often in PvP
um incandescent obviously being a very
very cool perk with that thing just
Burns Burns Burns people out in general
as far as being a 900 and just being
really steady and nice so very very nice
uh you know PVP as well as PVE uh
legendary
um
I still just obligatory wise you know I
need to uh get enough Reds to craft a
beloved beloved
um you know I don't snipe very often in
PvP I find it boring you know for a game
where personally for me I can move like
crazy on mnk and shotgunning is so much
fun and even riskier now with them
continuing to Nerf it
um it just you know it makes it
unrewarding in some ways but rewarding
in others you know me just finding a
shotgun roll that works you know best
for me and that you know kills most of
the time it's got to be damn near a god
rule these days for sure but it's
rewarding to move around people in close
quarters and be able to you know pick
folks off hopefully get that one hit
kill and move on to the next person
um but you know sniping is something
that is required at the highest levels
of PVP
um it's skill play sniping and skill
play most definitely so uh to be able to
at least craft one um even if I don't
get around to crafting it anytime soon
or even using anytime soon I need to get
a beloved so I find myself definitely in
containment probably a good amount but
there's some other like really dope
games outside of destiny that
um I really want to put a little bit of
time into the one that I am most looking
forward to that I'll probably play
sooner rather than later is a game
called neon white oh yeah so much fun oh
I'm like four or five levels four or
five chapters into that oh my God
dude I have had I haven't been able to
talk to anybody else about this yet
because I picked it up buddy of mine and
this is like this is the guy Cog that I
would do Forza lap time like ghost times
with same thing on neon white like he
beat me by like five hundredths of a
second I turned on a BM by like nine
thousandths of a second we're sitting
there just like fractions better trading
these like ghost times dude I have those
first two level like the first two are
really tight little levels God I haven't
had that much fun in a while
um yeah I just know when I picked that
game up on stream off stream but I mean
I pretty much only do stuff on stream
for the most part as far as gaming ditto
man I I know it's going to be the whole
stream I'm just gonna be sitting there
just speed running and having so much
fun man like the aesthetic friends on we
got to be friends on Steam because if
you start getting into that let me know
when you do because it's so much fun
okay yeah yeah send me uh like just just
send me a quick little like chat real
quick and I'll make sure that I add you
because I'll be hopping on Destiny right
after this so but yeah super super
looking forward to that when I when I
start playing that game you will see me
on it a lot
um I just don't know when I'll start so
so yeah good things yeah Maddie cannot
stop Raven and then our boy e on the
financial analyst uh was it Dom he's
also talking about that game yeah he's
been raving I've heard a lot of good
things about that it's it's got an the
skill ceiling on that thing to really
get those like fractions of time off
it's really well made because you get a
little bit better at the level and
you'll be like oh let me replay again
and you get enough and it shows you like
a hint of where you can really cut off
some time if you can like execute this
and you're like okay now I see where I
can drop another couple of seconds
so good yeah Neon white it is like a 20
25 it's not even that expensive but oh
that's a that's a game you can get
hooked on you get a couple friends
competing over times it's over it's so
much fun
yeah it's like normal price of like 25
bucks it's
it's worth it it's worth it I've seen
some I haven't played it yet but it's
been on my radar for a while because my
friend akatuki put me on to it
um and I've seen a decent amount of
gameplay to the point where I'm just
like wow this is okay this is gonna this
is I'm pretty sure this is going to uh
you know scratch the itch yeah and the
nice thing is like some of these levels
are like 15 seconds they're just a
little bursts yeah you can go and then
it's just trying to get better at it so
nothing takes that long in the game and
honestly there's a big there's probably
a whole lot of anime weeb story to it
but I just they give you a fast forward
button and you can skip all the dialogue
of which I've actually skipped a lot
because the gameplay is good but there's
a lot of dialogue that's probably
optional it's up to you
um but one of the times I hit fast
forward I was like I could have listened
to all there there's a lot in there so
yeah I skipped to the gameplay gameplay
is amazing
look at it now looks cool I'm working
through tunic and both that right now
tunics tunic at every turn is always
like damn it it's tunic's a really
really good game too
that one's on Game Pass
shout out to tunic
yeah shout out to Game Pass yeah
absolutely shout out to 200 hour jrpgs
that's all your life and any semblance
of
cohesion to your day you got a new one
you're working on no Justina bench three
yeah Xenoblade Chronicles three oh yeah
yeah do you game do you game in the suit
and tie as well oh yeah yeah all right
all right okay all right that's the
uniform it's beautiful I'm home alone
guys there's no one here there's a
question there's a question I can
totally ask you right now that would
break my YouTube monetization so I won't
so I'll just get after the podcast but I
can't
I think I know what that is the answer
is yes yes look it has multiple uses
okay blindfold all right uh rope right
okay I'm just saying the answer is yes
the answer is apparently yes anyway okay
um there we go
that's that's about all I got for the
show
um physics seriously a blast we team to
get off on tangents but love your wealth
yeah I love it man like the the the the
the Rapport of of you guys here it's
just so much fun it's just so much fun
we just get into just anything and I
love it thank you so much for for having
me back I come back I swear to God like
every other week it's just a just a
comment it's a lot of positivity a lot
of a lot of good vibes here and I
appreciate the invite it's always a
pleasure means a lot thank you very much
we appreciate the kind words a bunch and
again for you it's like the methodical
takes the thoughts of you know the
level-headed nature between all the
Twitter chaos it's always good to hear
somebody bring bring some thought to it
as opposed to just some emotion so we
appreciate you coming in and bullying me
PVP sandbox times yeah you're you're
always definitely one to bring in for
anything PVP if we get some season 19
chatter some survival some if we get
anything like Travis is hoping for a
rank thing I'm calling your number it's
definitely going to be that time sounds
good to me absolutely what else you guys
want that yeah that's that's going to be
a whole or hey honestly Travis may just
be like thank you everything sounds
amazing
it'll never be it'll never be that good
but you know the day they announce it I
think we should just like
shut up and let Travis read the talk
it happens I'll host the episode I'll
just be like welcome to the last word
with me I'm gonna talk about this today
yeah he just like takes the all of our
Windows just slide out of frame and
nobody has left yeah
I really don't try to talk about it
every episode but it would solve so many
problems that it just organically keeps
coming up it just keeps it'll be episode
yeah sure shout out to physics man it
was it was dope uh travel with you at
the gcx you know what I'm saying for a
little bit you know what I mean like
it's just cool man like I said love the
content love what you're doing always
The Vibes was always lit when you come
through it love with love to continue to
see your journey man it's really cool
stuff I'm glad that you're back that's
what I like too back in the mix yeah
yeah definitely you know everybody needs
to take a little bit of a break pay
attention to you know your mental
physical health self-care self-care
first and foremost and folks want to
know like how I stay level-headed with
so much you know going on and whether it
be Twitter whether it be on stream
whether it be somebody tries to troll or
like poke or prom you or something like
that it most definitely is kind of just
self-care That You Don't See you know
happening a lot of a lot of meditation I
die I always like swear about
conversation most definitely
um you know waking up in the morning and
just setting setting that mindset going
forward is is something that is uh you
know hugely beneficial when it comes to
just being level-headed and and not not
being so impulsive
especially online everybody wants to you
know immediately drop in and give give
their take and you know their feeling
about something it's just like you know
just step back for a second be mindful
and uh you know give something a little
more thoughtful meditation's huge on
that so yeah nice good stuff brother no
it's so important mental health is so
important and we we don't do a good job
of taking care of ourselves and taking
that step back sometimes I think it is
necessary man good good that's actually
great advice fantastic
yeah I mean I haven't even haven't been
streaming this much because added a
third dog inside my house and he's just
younger so it's like getting up early
because in Texas there's no good time to
give a husky a walk but about six
o'clock in the morning is about the best
time to do that so between my wife and I
it's two or one so getting up early I
have not been staying up as late cutting
the streams a little short but it's
sometimes just sitting there like same
thing I was like I'm just tired and it's
just I've been going to bed a little
earlier trying to catch up with some of
that it'll balance out but
you too I was like you've been killing
so many hours man you got it you burn
the candle at seven different ends so I
know you you need to just take like a
Saturday and Sunday shut your phone off
binge like this weekend stranger things
like or four different shows and nothing
bro
Chicago trip
chilling no IOP taking some some down
time nice downtown it's just nuts I
gotta recharge you got to recharge and
no content creation for a little bit and
it'll be there oh yeah it's never going
anywhere yes uh I will not be taking a
break um
ah the contrarian
health is a myth and uh no
personality trait for this guy I swear I
love it I was like what does Travis do
he's gonna say the opposite of whatever
is going on internally Lord contrarian
yeah no but seriously uh it's great
great hanging out with you guys uh ill
great meeting you this guy by the way
super super
nice dude in person very warm energy you
know you meet a guy and you can tell
that they're going to be a dick right
away it's very rare it's very rare that
you meet somebody and you can tell
they're not a dick right away but ill is
one of those people so super cool guy
love chatting with you
um I will one be one you you will beat
me just to be clear I mean you never
know you never know never know you never
know maybe me and my Prime I'd stayed a
chance but not right now yeah all right
so
um yeah uh yeah you can you can uh you
can find me on IG dot com previews
reviews outriders World Slayer check out
my Xenoblade review in a month when I'm
done with that uh and uh yeah that
that's it I'm glad to be here guys
thank you enjoy your your break coming
up right yeah it is yeah flights in the
morning tomorrow
um yeah just just excited then I I think
I'm still bringing the little man bring
a little series that's just a kitchen
game but you don't need to deal with all
the other stuff that's fair yeah it's a
Gateway it's a Gateway Cog you're gonna
do other things yeah we're gonna have
some fun but I want to shout out the uh
communities a couple times I was playing
Destiny this week and I got some really
nice last word messages
oh that's what's up that's a really nice
messages and then like there was one
Trials of it like a lot that like you
know you get you moving up on your card
I'm like wait a minute free love oh yeah
well I'm like at about five four no
losses got the mercy still in Tuck I'm
like okay it might be a good run and
then the fifth match there was someone
who recognized me and was like Hey [ __ ]
oh my gosh did he bend the knee
and it was a very casual batch that we
won so I got the [ __ ] Brock is so close
has six I had six but then lost and then
tomorrow I was like oh I was so
devastated so I I I would have e have
you gone Lighthouse with are you Lance
no is anybody going Lighthouse freelance
I was curious that was the closest I
gave
no I've never tried I've never been
freelance Lighthouse no I haven't even
been close
yeah it was it was a good run and then I
I made the once I made the adjustment to
um what is it the one with the the boots
that give you radiance
and I was it was like a Vex I I pretty
much had the Lydia Fusion joint going on
you know saying I switched to that and I
was doing really good and I had some
decent teammates for once I was like
it's a really cool exotic by the way too
because I mean even even beyond the buff
that it gives to fusions like reload all
your weapons with Icarus Dash is super
cool it's literally transverses on
demand and reload all your weapons is
huge I really have an appreciation for
those boots of PVP yeah
yeah what you got going uh yeah just
kind of working through a couple
different things working through tunic
probably play a little neon white on the
side and then I've got family my wife's
family is coming in town this weekend so
her parents are going to be here so just
kind of hanging out with them it's hot
as hell down here in Texas so probably
not going to be seen too much but the
nice thing is I got an excuse to go see
Top Gun again so I'm extremely pumped
because I enjoyed it the first time
through yeah I know 56 degrees in San
Fran enjoy dude Jesus
um we were talking about that before the
show yeah I was like oh what temperature
is it it's like 103 degrees here this
weekend or something like that so it's
fine
um but yeah so it's like it's gonna be
hot so maybe watching a couple things
but other than that just kind of
chilling this weekend probably won't be
streaming too much
and then back to it next week to see
what happens in week seven and then I
gotta get my iron Lord coming up but
yeah just probably getting to the point
where for you know the final six seven
weeks like solstice isn't gonna take too
long so it's gonna be some variety
thrown in there gotta gotta keep the
balance of like can't Overkill Destiny
so much when you finally get back into a
new season you hate it already so the
variety in the latter part of the Season
always helps so it's a great time to
catch up on backlog yeah Travis gotta be
excited I'm actually gonna um for uh
outriders I love this review and I still
think the game is funny Destiny can
learn a couple things especially UI and
and management and builds they really
can so I like crafting for sure yes I
like to see the crashing I love what you
said kind of how the the end game works
and stuff like that so yeah I'm gonna
I'm gonna find out a world Slayer see
what's going on stay story though you
know what is original they don't take
they self seriously like I'm to the
point where they know they're goofy
there's nothing with this that and they
just I don't know man sometimes I
sometimes I think that but then if you
play the end game you're like oh they
are for sure taking them so seriously
and it's kind of like you're kind of
cringy it really makes me wonder yeah I
was howling
how you cut that up was nice thank you
did you like the ending where the guy
goes
yo I love that review
that was really you did a fantastic job
with that one you caught it all the good
points but you also gave credit that
look the core gameplay is still fun as
hell yeah the last thing about our
Riders it doesn't get enough credit for
that obviously they had their glitches
in their server and all that stuff but
there's some things about it I still
like yeah it's a great game yeah
well thank everybody for chat for being
here today thank you physics for being
here of course a pleasure but definitely
hours to make sure when you join us so
we appreciate the time and you are
always welcome sir if you're just like
hey you guys got anybody
some point I gotta get another
collaboration again I got a couple
people that I want to line up because we
had a good mix the other time I want to
get a couple PVP heads together and see
what happens
let me know too because I'll definitely
suggest a couple people that uh you know
I have a good rapport with and and we
could definitely we can get definitely
go in yeah I can think of a couple we
might talk right after the show
that guy that made you go to orbit would
be a good one to get on
blue man I'm telling you that's that's
the homeboy right there for sure he
shares the exact my birthday was the
20th of June he shares the exact same
birthday as me oh so yeah yeah everyone
has a similar mindset for sure so I'll
plug if you don't mind I'll plug a
couple things so of course you know
folks can find me ill physics on most
platforms you can find my link tree of
course on in my Twitter bio to find out
you know the platforms that I'm not ill
physics on it's just illus physics on a
couple of other ones
um but uh if it's okay to plug another
podcast absolutely okay yeah massive
breakdowns oh absolutely oh I had a
great great chat with kit recently that
dropped today so definitely he's gonna
be coming on the show
in a month or two yeah yeah kid is kid
is definitely awesome and we had a
fantastic conversation about hand
cannons primarily
um but you know a little bit of course
um whenever it comes to me about
community and and kind of mindset but uh
but yeah go check that out that just
dropped today and I've I had a great
time on that episode recorded it talk
about audacity messing it up messing up
I had to record that like three that was
the third time we recorded that almost
that entire podcast oh my God so um so
yeah bam audacity messed up the first
time the second time my power went out
we lost the entire recording
um and uh so we had to record it three
times but we got it done we got it done
so but uh definitely go check that out
and it's a pleasure to be here thanks so
much for having me yeah great podcast
yeah all right well for episode number
204 as we wrap up June we are about
halfway through 2022 which is a little
crazy to say so next time you guys see
us we'll be in the second half of 2022
so for this episode it has been
the last one last word